[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sir
yes sir
sunday sunday sunday
the realm is outside canada's best 100
salute to the gods salute to the cause
no doubt there we go gerald back up
early on that sunday i see the video
brother i appreciate you salute bunty
wachuan ilp what's going on you done
know
nico hunt gang gang boozy the clown
kicking the door waving the ps4 yo
you wallet
jig and jay got the little man going on
right now absolute salute you know me
i'm max okay let's go heat all right all
right miami the building jimmy but i
know it should be my life let me know
what's up with that
nico xbox in japan now's the time to
bring back scare oh y'all going extra
x x is that simple i know right little
man mommy boy all right all right
bearded panties outside
lillian master yeah yeah i lp today joel
wolfe what up [ __ ] and the rest of the
lord looking forward to the shout out
john wolfe salute i got a chance to
watch your um podcast so you want to get
joints i see you moving out there
you know i'm saying salute good content
akw
salute levels are good thank you thank
you always checking it out awful grim
bones good afternoon aurora wolf i see
you
what else we got what else we got
so yeah we look everybody in the room
we're gonna see what's going on oh golf
balls home today all right the only day
all right black truth what's going on
what's good kale three salutes a little
slow everything good on a sunday i see
y'all rocking with us that's what's up
get everybody in here talk to the people
what's going on guys i'm hearing an echo
it's uh it's
it's it's been a it's been a long night
i just woke up like 15 minutes yeah you
looking too comfortable in this chair i
missed the old days
so so you missed me in pain i don't know
i thought we were friends what's going
on here
putting up friend applications
on youtube
oh [ __ ] was funny as hell the attic
sounding good that is good we are happy
you know what i'm saying we're going to
see what's up with king it's one time
last night i know he did the show let's
see what's going on with him and solve
should be pulling up
you know what i planned on doing i
planned on like sitting in the wooden
chairs
[Laughter]
solve
just the lord's old school you know
if we have a surprise we may we may but
no guarantees i'm looking forward to
talking about brothers anyway so i will
talk to y'all get y'all with these uh
dallas cars
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all haven't messed up and turned
me to an animal and headless be swearing
they real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social lower my city but i'm
still by coastal
[Music]
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell the uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal i got
it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want wanna compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i'm addicted to flipping and
snapple and making it flammable this is
that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social my city but i'm still by
coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell an uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled but i'm gonna be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger that's who
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start it regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with
the gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line yo this is
that standard this is what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on debt number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time gotta support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast
peace
[Music]
for addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i know
it's my destiny work to kind of who
cares if you fly if you steal a mosquito
you swear you ain't something but really
be stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that you can't even still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right all right let's test some
levels real quick like checks
let's get the get the suave in there
[Laughter]
and we are live
welcome to the iron lords podcast llc
and also live on lords lordsofgaming.net
episode number 258 that's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day and today
i forgot to put the topics into this
discussion
[Laughter]
so
and bungie and censorship to talk i was
so happy we have a guest i forgot to say
what i was going to talk about
unprofessionalism let's go so let's
salute the song for the save so let's
introduce
us let's just let's introduce the four
horsemen of gaming those were here we
wouldn't have cared that there's a guest
either
i still have my jaffy notes up i'm like
yeah this is wrong
[Laughter]
i'm blaming you to start introducing
yo that's hilarious
let's introduce the full husband of
gaming those original laws of the realm
nicholas the difficult gay conqueror
lord of his own world and the how of the
young wolf my man lord addict are we
doing of the attic show doing pretty
good i would be exhausted if it wasn't
for this little focus stuff here
actually
it's it
it you know um
show you how you speak how you work that
powder okay
what's the flavor
put the flavor off it looks like it says
sour salad
let's talk about it there's gg right now
this stuff yeah advanced gigi you put
this uh you put the source
you use this stuff you yeah you use this
stuff
you be up for days man
i don't even know what day it is i was
been working for you bro you know what
i'm saying how you guys moving it's good
what day is it
[Laughter]
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to buy some more because i
ate eight nine scoops yesterday
[Laughter]
it's definitely a good product uh you
know it what it does i don't really have
a whole lot of um
a lot of photo i have to mute that yeah
a lot of
experience with stuff like that but it
does like
it does keep me like
when you take like certain like things
that keep you up like five hour energy
yeah yeah like i i've always noticed
like there's like a huge crash at the
end yeah
but like i don't i don't really feel it
with this stuff it just feels like
it just naturally keeps me up a little
longer and like i don't feel like
repercussions like my body's rejecting
it afterwards
fall asleep that's the side effects it's
not forever
no but it's true right
like you don't you'll feel i get that
man i'll be right back
i'm done you're ridiculous
anyway what you was playing sir
uh
i've actually jumped back on destiny uh
you know key
forte calls me the uh do my homework at
the last minute person yeah
uh so what's funny is i was level like
15 or 20 in my season rank and i'm like
level 75 or 76 now oh yeah i paid you
for that season i didn't even get
everything out of it yeah it's so good
on tuesday
the thing that i always like from the
from the season pass is like the
ornaments yeah
i've never really cared about the emote
but there's this wing emo where like you
fly in the air
and i'm looking at them like i want that
i want to
i want to fly so yeah that's that's what
i'm doing currently uh i will uh you
know let me let me go oh we got the news
oh really oh we need a bag man shout out
to secret labs
this is a magnet
i've never seen that so so we're not
going back to the windshield no more
we're not going to take it back to the
essence oh no no more wicked chairs
[Laughter]
i will go back to the wooden chair
when i'm streaming tetris
keep it to the esses so that's because
if if i'm in pain i might as well be
physically in pain too
and one last thing didn't you uh review
a game uh this series
yeah i reviewed dolman it's uh out for
all the consoles
i don't know if you guys checked it out
it's kind of like a
like a
demon so i would say like the speeds a
little bit more on like demons like dark
souls and demon cells like it's a
it's a it's a little bit slow um it
might be a little bit slower than those
games but what i like about it is
it's got really good boss mechanics now
uh you know it's got a little bit of uh
dart uh
death space vibes to it like
especially like when you're aiming down
sights it feels real dead space death
space-ish and what's funny is like the
suits kind of look like the suits that
isaac wears in dead space
the biggest thing i actually that i
forgot to mention in the review because
i have like a i had like a five page
notes on on the game but i i don't know
why but i wanted the aesthetics in death
face the farther you go and the more
upgrades the shoot changes it looks
different yeah and i kind of would have
liked that to have happened in that game
where like you get to actually change
the suit wait but did they let you
customize in the beginning they let you
make it different colors and that's
pretty much all that's the extent there
is there is one suit where you can look
like iron man like you literally look
like iron man like the the gold plating
and everything maybe a little bit
different than iron man but it similarly
looks the same
it was a fun game now obviously you guys
go check out the review mm-hmm
yeah that's up on the website uh
[Laughter]
i gotta get my focus i'm out here with
the competitors oh no we ain't doing
that coming in
i didn't think about it i should have
mixed some of that silence yeah
that's what i'm talking about
we have a uh
we have a review out too for the website
so definitely go to lordsgaming.net and
check
it's been a pretty uh chill week but one
thing i will say is um i'm gonna cancel
my game pass subscription services are
you announcing it are you letting the
world i'm i'm announcing it man i'm
screaming i'm talking
after you see the ftc's on you i just
want to make sure because did i heard
fcc making people do that man they know
better
i just want to make sure i don't know
and of course we have almost technical
gaming lord the single solo player gamer
who lives with a single player
experience and also the softstradamus
the lord of clarity and lord patron of
the iron bank sorry the chat is throwing
mad chances and they're distracting me
louis
how are we doing sir
chillin man i'm doing good i'm doing
good
as always yeah i i i'm not even living
up to my moniker man i don't have time
to play a damn thing you know you're
still moving you're still moving yeah so
what i've been doing is actually a lot
of audiobooks right so at least that
keeps me occupied or whatnot so this was
actually going to be my topic but i'll
talk about it a little bit now i i went
through uh reggie's book okay uh
disrupting the game yeah i've got the
the from the bronx something and back
whatever he's from the bronx yeah oh
yeah boogie there yeah you know
it's a really interesting book because
reggie
reggie really did come in at a time for
nintendo where they needed to change the
message well they might have been a rap
like
and it was like it was just this perfect
storm of this dude that came in and
wasn't afraid to challenge uh you know
kind of the iron grip that nintendo of
japan really had over the messaging in
at nintendo
and
you know
he talks a lot about his entire career
right he started at procter gamble after
college and whatnot
and uh you know he had from the very
beginning he was this dude that's like i
have these ideas or whatever and you
know
and the cool thing about the book is
that at the end of kind of every chapter
he he he has something that he calls the
so what right so
so what means like hey okay so you read
all this what does it mean right so it's
kind of the lesson that he learned from
each thing in his life that has happened
to him and how he applies it either to
life or to business right and it's
always these you know these very this
these these these quotables and stuff
that kind of give you direction in terms
of business and life right um
so at the end of every chapter he does
that um and it's very cool because at
the end what you do what you see is this
kind of very rounded picture of who
reggie is what his ideals are what his
morals are and how he's carried all of
that into every aspect of his life
and i tell you uh but the great thing is
that it culminates at nintendo a company
that absolutely needed him at that time
and
the things that he managed to do there
pushing you know pushing back against
certain things like like do you guys
remember like kane you remember that you
know when the 3ds came out the 3ds was
like
we're like why is this thing 270.
he fought against that from the
beginning he was like no this needs to
be two hundred dollars yeah and at the
end they had to they had to concede
eventually after right they stopped
making an old-school clam shell junk
right no this is 3ds
back for on the
he was there from the ds days for sure
but in the 3ds i specifically remember
when he
one day when they came out with that the
the idea of 3d that was the time when
the 3d tvs were big they kind of rolled
that wave
and
they were like already they took that
out of there yeah yeah yeah so it was do
you remember the ambassador program that
if you went you bought early and you
paid at 270 or whatever was 290 almost
um they gave you 20 free games
afterwards because they dropped the
price they dropped the price i think
less than yeah that's what i'm saying
they're doing this error so this is this
is all dude
it was one of them
reparations
when reggie get on the show i need my 20
games back reggie yeah
so you know i tell you so it was just
one of those things that he really
showed like he had a great relationship
with wada he had a great relationship
with with miyamoto and that sort of
allowed him to sort of the inroads and
and the fact of the matter is that he
kept proving himself into things that he
kind of pushed for
when they when they played out in the
market a lot of times he was right you
know
uh you know he and he says he admits so
he was wrong about certain things
he's wrong give me one that he was wrong
but he felt he's wrong oh what the heck
was it uh
i think it was it was the wii u thing oh
crazy thing
i think
some of the wii u stuff um there was
something in particular i'm not
remembering specifically what it was now
but specifically says like he's like
this is what happens when you make and
he says so what so so what is that i
messed up
and
because there was one part earlier in
his career where he said he knew
something was the right thing to do i
think it's when he was working for pizza
hut
and he did he went ahead and pushed
something and did it without the
approval from above knowing it was the
right thing to do
it played out well in the market right
it played out well it was successful but
the problem was that he didn't follow
protocol no he did it and one of the big
big things he said is that you always
have to when you believe in something
really and truly you have to do the work
to bring people to
to your side to your side no that's fact
that's right you have to have allies
big corporate facts yeah so he didn't do
that yeah start making pizza dane
sanctions
it was like i forgot what it was called
it was like some humongous pizza
something that didn't work because it
was made differently and it turned out
you know at the end of the day it was
cheaper or whatever but what happened
was that the end product was like super
greasy and not appealing so it was just
one of those things where
in the short term it made the money in
the long term it kind of messed up but
at the end of the day he pushed forward
with something and kind of just did it
without permission yeah thanks to the
situation
it was successful it was like they made
money but he was like i was a dead man
walking at that point yeah at that point
let me get the reggie shebang
regardless if they made money they saw
reggie as like a rebel like that yeah
like he can't control him you gotta
watch him he'll push the butt though so
yeah all right so all of that all of
those learnings right he took with him
to nintendo and it's like when you see
all the stuff and it's because reggie's
very
the dude came to manhattan was like yo
yeah let me get the reggie shebang they
was like
up in the bronx man i get the joint with
the avocados
[Music]
feel
it other m metroid other m was a they it
did not
in the beginning they thought this is
this distinguished metroid and with team
ninja was going to be fantastic
at the end of the day the product did
not live
up so and it's things that you know at
it's your job you have to promote it
whatever but at the end of the day
sometimes your heart isn't into certain
things you see certain things yeah right
what's the name of it is disrupting the
game hold on a second it's cool i'll
look it up but yeah that was it though
that is fantastic no doubt no get him on
the show to ask him about his slices
yeah yeah we can't figure it out
love to do that because all the people
all right reggie only gives me 30 minute
maybe hour interviews depending on the
show that you're on right
but a lot of them ask the questions
specifically about things in the book
whatever obviously they focus on
nintendo
i want to sit with this man and be like
because
there was a part when he talked about
kind of a little bit of a beef that he
got in with his brother and the bx right
and he was like
outside shooting the fight
reggie was a big kid right oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah what he says in the book is
yeah me and my brother were tough kids
reggie was in the boogie dancing
he was talking about a moment when you
know sunday he he and his brother went
down to the well they got to buy the
sunday daily news right yes that pops
and they got robbed by a couple of dudes
right that's the bronx and that moment
and that moment he was like yo we can't
we're tough kids but these dudes were
bigger than us the smart thing to do was
just give them the money hell for clay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so when moms came down and moms came
down and she walked with them like who
is it whatever and then there was a
whole big thing where in front of some
other you know hard-hitting dudes on the
street
the mother beefed with them and the dude
was like give them back the money
whatever so it kind of taught them a
little bit of a lesson about you know
what the streets were whatever but he
did not elaborate on the fact that he
and his brother were tough kids
yeah so i want to have a conversation
with reggie like from the beginning to
the end like that would be fantastic
because everybody asks you know the
questions you expect of course of course
shout out shout outs
shout out to reggie that'd be fantastic
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this aka the access
game app
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved laura king how we doing sir
we're doing fantastic shout out to david
benavidez and david lemieux it's just a
case of everybody that uh came out last
night for combat talk with the king
thank you i appreciate everybody that
hung out and you know i had some of
those uh watermelon martinis that we
used for free
with delicious uh two fights yo tiger
woods son is a beast really uh he goes
by the monika of gomez um
you know
i've done that
is he tigers go tight why is he talking
they do look like tiger woods like i
thought i thought you was legitimately
meeting your son was fighting like i was
about to ask like when did he get into
that when did he get into boxing
allegedly tiger was
moving around he was moving around
moving around but oh boy look like tiger
woods
just like tiger woo
i'm not gonna lie man i like him i like
him
shout out to people's right
people's heads
he was the most official dr dude in that
drives like yo that's a good time
so um
yeah so that was the the fight before
the main card and he was fighting like
the boxing version of the korean zombies
this dude named coda okay it was a wild
looking fight it was dope though and
then we got david benavidez versus
lemieux and um a big guy versus a a good
big guy versus a good little guy the
good big guy is always going to win and
um you know he just knocked him out in
the third round uh somebody called it
last night that it was in three rounds
they called it and it was it was a dope
thing so i do appreciate everybody
that's coming out um what i've been
playing yes sir
your boy back on fortnite oh again
back
yeah they now yo anna brought the season
pass
i'm out of control brought the season
pass for fortnite but didn't buy for
well i brought it for destiny
i got to get back on destiny just to
finish up for um
uh for the you know close up the shop on
the money that i gave them um but oh
also doing elder ring in between okay uh
trek naomi and
it was another it was it was another
game that i was playing but um
oh every time attic wreck i'm sick of
tired of that recommendation oh
because you know he'll recommend a
really good game i get distracted go
down this rabbit hole with this really
good game
and then boom i'm done two three hours
and i could have did something else for
my two three hours
so
you're mad that i recommend good games
listen i got no problem with it because
he's reviewing everything lately every
time i turn i pop up it says iron lord's
podcast a new review i'm like
hit his back
atticus out here working as hard as hell
mm-hmm i was watching his stream the
other day his stream was uh entertaining
it was about domain and uh he was
running down the hallway so he goes to
these spiders there's these eggs on the
floor right and he goes and he said well
what we're gonna do is we're gonna first
no it was a fire dude down the hallway
he said we're gonna set it off on the
fire dude so he runs down the hole and
set it up on the fire dude beat the fire
dude up he said now what we're going to
do is we're going to deadly go over here
and touch these eggs and bring them out
one by one well they want to listen to
what he was saying all three of the
dudes jump out at him
i guess i gotta fight all three even
that one
was entertaining i mean it's
entertaining stuff so anytime attic is
streaming please go check that stuff out
but other than that i've been chilling
can't wait for vacation uh because
[Music]
yeah yeah not for sure definitely
definitely we all definitely gonna be
taking it
yeah you're never gonna vacation
you never you never go no doubt and of
course we have a gaming ninja himself
this be lord cognito spreading that
realistic remnant i'm gonna i'll pee not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear shout out to
defining duke had a great episode miles
don't be was in the building south the
miles you know what i'm saying just
talking that talk and everything that's
going on the aftermath for the crazy
week um yeah man good topics check it
out it should be up on free 99 on last
saw stamp media youtube also ultimate we
were talking about on playstation um
plus a little bit what we've discussed
today and how it compares the game past
a little bit of that that's up on the
joints shout out to thai guy travis
ibonte's last word was fire we have our
man castle content great content creator
really good knowledgeable guy has some
really good discussions there i talked
also about pvp and some other stuff
going on there as far as me man finally
got back to a little bit of gaming
you know i finished track to yomi this
week and um man
phenomenal phenomenal job i mean it's
not perfect it's definitely got some
issues as far as um only issues just
like the combat
that that turn to the side turn to this
side joint you know what i'm saying and
it's not gonna that part ain't gonna be
for everybody and the pairing is weird
because it's like soft note is like we
parry dudes like we like that feel
and like
it's weird the timing is like you have
to parry a little earlier
and i got it down but i could see why
some people were complaining about it
but when you do it it's a dance
it's a it's you know what i'm saying and
yo that joint i'm gonna tell you right
now be like
it threw me off cause i was like you
know typical samurai you killed my
master you know i'm like what story you
really gonna yo
the story is fire i ain't gonna spoil yo
the story and then it take a turn
that like
yo remember this joint i'm gonna i don't
care if i remember this i i'm afraid
i'll show you in a minute but there was
a bad sister gay cool it was another
sarah it's called considered and satan
of course bro
that little gay as a kid scared the hell
out of me like i never had japanese
horror before i didn't know what
japanese horror is so i was like what's
going on these monsters oh my god like
what is it like
and like the environment made me
uncomfortable
like they got like that a little
spiritual side a horror sign that i
didn't see coming
and yo
it's fire and then they got some
decisions you gotta make it yo track the
yomi
yo super new ninja approved man i am
very i was very impressed with that joy
so yeah finish that joint and um i'm
still doing my mlb the show joint shout
out to the best dude oh that's what's up
shout out to the free yeah
shout out definitely shout out the game
plans i'm keeping my gamepad
just let
ain't got that value even though they
got all a value in earlier
is you know if you want to talk about
you know value and game pass
it's it's value to whoever you know has
a subscription it is 10 to 15 a month if
people if people don't feel like it's
it's value to you yeah no absolutely
we're not planning that yeah then go
yeah then go and unsub like oh i do feel
like you know everyone go on twitter and
vocalize yeah see that's my like i'm
just not that guy i'm not the guy that
got him like hey guys i'm breaking up
with my girl like i'm there i'm not that
dude so it just is funny to me that's
always like okay everybody has to
announce this okay cool i'm okay with
that too because as we've seen when
microsoft gets that kind of
kind of you know feedback uh
that that's what they know definitely
when they get that right hook microsoft
comes back with the okay we're getting
the bullies we're we're hiring the
bullies to come back on the bullies no
no it's just like you know you know
people want to voice that concern voice
it because uh i love a microsoft with
their back against the wall because they
end up i feel like every time their
backs against the wall they're willing
to spend more money to to to hit them
out outside the wall so i think it's a
little weird that you know you want to
cancel uh right before an event but it's
just like look like if you don't feel
like it's a value to you then i don't i
don't blame you weird i think i think
it's a lot of huffing and puffing that
yeah you know
how many people to be honest to be
honest if you're paying the 15 a month
when there's so many deals you can get
out there for buying in bulk like that's
dumb like i'm unless you unless your two
multi-year subscription is run out you
should not be paying a fifteen dollar
monthly fee for the future you are not
financially equipped
here we go long haul so you know
when
microsoft this year especially with the
star field delay and the red fall delay
you know as far as like aaa quality game
sure it's it's a little lacking but to
be honest with you like
they haven't really had that all of this
year so it's just like
i feel like microsoft does good with the
with the aaa stuff but i feel like that
like the tunic the indie games they know
they do go with the double a and the
indy they're killing that triple a
really like i remember phoenix point
came into it the other day so it's just
like look like it's like i said man
go ahead vocalize your pity because you
know i'm hoping microsoft vocalize it on
my timeline because i don't know
microsoft season man that's what i want
question is evil west game pass yes it
is
yeah
yeah it is hold on one second i got to
turn my radio off
yeah this this this is the problem with
individuals feeling like oh yeah i don't
know what starfield was
is or what it's gonna be i can't miss
something i never had and i don't know
what red fault is
was or what it's going to be
can't miss it and i didn't care about it
so when people was like yo it's a delay
it's a delay so what everybody's like
what are we going to do
i think i think what it is
you know what i don't like attic i don't
like people in my dms like
what's what's going on they messed up my
christmas yo for real b
i think yeah is less about them well you
know individuals on twitter and stuff
saying that they're cancelling game pass
and more about a statement
yeah it's a principle yeah it's a prison
right i think
i think you're a low-key seeing
game pass like not necessarily get
boycotted but it's like look i don't
like the way that some of these uh
titles have been moving some of these
delays have been hitting i feel like
those were the majority of the value to
my service right i but but why do you
always have to use another
service to attack another service like
it's like look i i get it i do like i
it's like i said the only thing that's
kind of weird is you would do it before
an event like i feel like if you want to
make a statement like that you would do
it after this event in june because what
i
mean
two weeks away
they want to downplay the event see a
lot of city i like this game really
hardcore dudes that's with xbox this is
not that all right this is really the
fake news what are you gonna do there's
no games
yeah those are those dudes yeah oh you
know cause uh early in the year we we
got two broken games that did come out
we have a service that's showing up that
is half big but what are you going to do
oh i feel so bad that's the two games
that you were looking for
man if you don't get off my time they're
going they're going to the legs dude
shout out to jw for doctoring documents
on
the biggest thing you're seeing now
right now i don't think you're seeing
people come out saying that they're
unsubbing the game pass i think you're
just seeing a
what's what i'm looking for it's like i
said just like like a low-key boycott
and it's not even
it's just one of those like
look
you cause i mean let's be right here it
wasn't just like last year that
microsoft said they wanted to put a game
every three or four months they said
that years ago
and i think people just got to the point
now where it's like
you we need to see games
listen it's just it's just everybody has
the right to cancel whatever they have
if they unsatisfied you know i'm saying
that that's not where i'm going with it
my my thing was just like you know i
just find it funny to to publicly have
to keep saying something to to to get
some type of
i don't do it like if i'm stopping then
i'm stopping and it's like it's like i
think the reason that's done though is
because i don't think these people are
canceling the service i think they're
just trying to make a point like yeah
i'm trying to do it well show me the
receipts but don't come back
anyway that's what i'm saying stand on
your square stand on your screen
are you out like what else when i
started well what i've seen like since
we've been saying since uh cog made me
get twitter and all this other stuff
right
i've noticed it was dudes that were
green that was like i'm going over the
playstation and
[Music]
rotten in denmark and then
and then they come back
oh man xbox is doing so well i'm back
y'all
i think the reason nobody missed you
nobody kids you left nobody
no nobody was checking for you i think
the reason that i consider that
different is because that was mainly
told
said by people
that didn't want actual better for the
xbox brand they they just wanted to
troll the brand
like i don't necessarily like when i see
some of these people on twitter saying
they're canceling the game fast i don't
see them hating on the service i don't
see them you know wanting the service to
like where they come out publicly say
they want something to be better but
they don't i generally see people that's
like look you guys need to do better on
how you release games and until then i'm
gonna have to pull out for a little bit
that's fine do do knock yourself out do
it do what you gotta do
anyway back with what i was saying won't
leave the light on
back at what i was saying i was playing
check the yo v playing everybody the
show with your game president obviously
um destiny get my guardian games
finished enough get my little torches
because i think i got to get that mug i
got to get that royal iron lord tinkered
that they got so i gotta finish up the
platinum joining shout out to forte
shout out to dj orals
yeah we gotta get the platinum you know
what i'm saying
what's that what's that what do you
think about platinum on xbox what are
you talking about here
on the top
i'll talk about the event you gotta get
the platinum medals
what you doing blue boy uh man don't
wait oh
[Music]
[Applause]
he's stupid anyway that's been it for me
oh shout out to you uh okay i did uh
stink in one of your streams rest in
peace vernon forest didn't know that
when you said that oh yeah they know
that
i actually watched the stream that got
off
and started watching his fights remember
when he roughed up shade
that was our greatest night don't
remember it was me that's the night that
was the night your mom said
because we didn't let people in the
house yes like they paid for the
pay-per-view me and you paid that fifty
dollars
she was like why are they everybody
sitting on the stoop and just y'all two
in the house because they didn't pay
their pay
this is game pass
we have boxing game passing the crib and
if you wanted this guy he was outside he
could not partake
as a fact i watched that yeah and then
oh what happened
this you might like look down on me but
we used to order the ufc pay-per-views
and blame and blame it on my mom
ordering wow
like a bunch of like you know those
movies that's on like uh hbo and stuff
um
like
it on that like the the rent movies that
like the movies that just came at the
movie theater like why is the the my i
remember my stepdad would be like why
did the
why is the the the cable bill like fifty
dollars more i'm like i don't know mom
needs to stop running movies yo you sad
you savage yeah we should do that
shout out to shout out to oh russia
pete's voted for us and then oh shout
out
to you saw the old man was outside
beside that old man too and silva and
this is silva out here knocking people
out with 47 in boxing boys
yeah they say like it's supposed to
because i guess he called them out and
their assistant edison been fighting
like three or four fights and he looking
i
i'm gonna tell you this big paul better
stay the hell away from this dude
because i i i saw a documentary on him i
watched the documentary on him we never
really got the real good years of
enemies
we got the um
you know in japan
man oh man this dude is a savant and and
it's very good that he hitched his wagon
to floyd
so that you know yeah the fighters or
he's taking him on a world tour i saw
the sheik in the back room with floyd in
abu dhabi
and you know that place was a landfill
like a week ago and he had so much money
he built a whole stadium we're going to
do this on the aircraft carrier and
we're going to fight
and anderson silva is getting his money
now oh salute yeah
i don't even think about that i didn't
even think about that part you're right
short-changed he was a show
i remember
i remember because i i that's when i was
like bigger than the mma thing when like
anderson was on his like eight it got to
the point we were watching ufc when we
didn't even care who he was fighting we
just watching it's like he was so
dominant we were just watching like we
ain't missing the pay-per-view he would
actually lose yeah yeah because it was
just like how he going
it was literally years of people
doubting anderson silva and years of
that dude knocking people out doubting
anderson silva i'll be honest man i
still look at that wideman knockout i'm
like i don't know that was just we it
would seem very soft i don't know oh
cool you got to get wild with that look
i don't know
i mean the next time when he broke his
leg the next shot was real you know with
the blank blue
[Laughter]
about that sorry you want to get the
super chat said then we get into the uh
yeah no doubt so uh we'll start off with
a super chat that came in at the last
minute last week so we got uh thx 1138
with the five dollar super chat mcu post
credit t's i guess he's talking about uh
doctor strange yeah
okay so
i i do want to talk about that for a
brief second uh we are going to start
being a little bit better with you guys
when it comes to stuff like that the
problem is when stuff like that airs and
we watch like movies it's so hard to
know when all of us are going to watch
something or like it's hard to like all
of us communicate on that kind of level
and then most of the time by the time we
all watch it it'll be like a saturday in
the next days at the the show
yeah well we're going to try like if two
of us watch it we're going to try to
just do like as many as of us can what
the attic is saying is me and attic is
going to be doing these oh
[Laughter]
is if we have to stay up a little later
just a little bit yeah
you got that sour right yeah you got
that sound i see
what else we got
hold on a second let me copy paste one
more but like i said we
uh you know me and king are trying to
and that the uh the other lord's seen it
then you know we will do something that
it's just like look like
and i i wasn't even really bringing up
the other like
king is the one making this ridiculous
this is hard it's hard for all of us to
watch the same thing in the same time
frame
to the movie
anyway
while i'm doing i see some merch come in
or shout out someone bought that red
class got the red classic ilp salute say
something in the comments got there
somebody bought the uh four ho actually
know the gaming knights of the realm
hoodies the gaming nice that's the merch
with all of us for real somebody got
that iop beanie said uh rip snorter oh
yeah we did we shouted him out he said
right in the summertime what the hell's
going on australia he said rock this out
at fairfax australia i love the show
lads keep crushing it that somebody got
take a picture next to that diesel
kangaroo did somebody anonymous say your
name somebody got the little man hoodie
okay so i just bought that guys i guess
there's really
little man is in vogue right now
i will say that when it comes to the
merchandise me and king are working with
artists
we're going to be rebranding how we do
merchandise
yes cool yeah and once it's gone you
won't be able to get it
yeah
we're gonna do like a lot oh yeah except
for you know if king's in charge of that
you'll be able to get an extra three
and that's that's why you got to shame
them when you can that's what i'm trying
to tell you getting while you got him
that's what we do bless you sir bless
you sir see that's what happens when you
go against me i'll make you sneeze what
else you got
all right so we got a hard to find two
dollars to be chat attic could probably
build a house in 20 minutes right now
okay i don't know what that means
wow that that i got that joke and you're
rude sir
that went over my head i went way over
by him
is he talking like does white dudes with
beards build houses
he got that paul bunyan thing going on
yeah yeah so so pretty much like you you
paid to try to clown me on something
that you can't do okay
you can't build the house on fire that's
a hard to find there we go
shout out to them cool five dollars
people who had their subs in 2018 2019
when there was barely anything new at
all and talking about they cancelling
themselves i know right yeah when they
had nothing but bare bones they had 85
games
i'm out of here now when he got 500 i'm
out
there we got necromancer zale 10 to be
chat with my with microsoft announcing
starfield delay before the show they had
to know there were issues for a while
question is with the early announcement
do they have a plan to cover uh with the
time they had i mean they're going to
show the game
they're going to be shown did they
really know
i don't i don't know i don't know about
that part i think it was done at the
last minute bill walked in the room and
said show me your bill he said i don't
like your bills
[Laughter]
yo by the way let me see your bills
[Laughter]
once we get this once we get this uh
show me your bill thing going it's gonna
be amazing if phil wore those to this
show we need that show you're building
[ __ ] every time he each other guys
he didn't win if we want to go to each
game
and he's like even they'd be eating he'd
be talking to like bonnie ross and you
like yo bonnie no he's gonna yeah
he has a trench coat yeah
for 20
good afternoon my brothers i hope
everyone is doing great this weekend i
missed the civil war already but all
good things come to an end sadly yeah
he's basically he's on twitter
the biggest question man if the the xbox
civil war who's iop getting drafted
i don't know i'm not part of that call
me if i drag you
you better not call me
yeah drawn tj five dollars
philly
missouri i bet after the activision deal
microsoft buys ea
i don't think they'd get away with
buying the a we're gonna talk about it
then we got hard to find once again five
dollars of a chat you were amped up on
the powder addict apology accepted
that's what the powder do yeah gotta
make it
different look i i don't know because
you said apology accepted if you took
offense anything i said
they look like i just be joking with
these super chats like they i don't know
i never intentionally try to upset
anyone because i because it is weird he
put apology accepted i just want to make
sure that i didn't mean anything it's
not good
like offensive and the thing i said
he's not cheeks he when he got a good
chair he's not cheeks
don't care cheeks is out in these
streets
[Music]
been a month yeah it's been a month it
feels longer though
i don't know that was long i smelt as
long in general yeah
all right so
this 10 gift card giveaway goes
[Music]
mason cochran okay shout out to mason
shout out to the government out there
but that's all i got that's what i like
absolutely get that get that
dollar gift card giveaway and that goes
to
gamers play
sir all right salutes a little game is
play no doubt all right there we go
reggie
of the reggie special
nobody wants to read this but moving on
we got our tea spray giveaway for the
month of may
[Music]
congrats to all hit me up in the dms if
i have your uh if i have your twitter
info i will hit you up and
see what's good
i just want you guys to know i am going
to start
talking to all of them
about uh setting up a spoiler cast for
the halo tv show for the first season uh
it will be on members only and um uh
patreon for
oh we lost him oh he lost him yeah it is
master cheeks was not about that yeah
definitely not about that hopefully we
get a wonderful show it was a fantastic
show and i do love this show
and we won't have that type of
difference
was
y'all put free attic in the
he's locked down he says something
slanderous about the show please if you
have it in your heart microsoft to make
some calls on our behalf to get my main
out of life
you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
yo somebody said hashtag put money on
his
he stood up against the system and they
got him man but we got him hey
watch your mouth yeah we got you at the
vr we got you on the vr fan we got you
there
oh gross you already replaced it with
grump what timing
they got they got someone more padable
that like the halo series
search for context jump keep keep my
streaming servant's name out your mouth
powerball has hit us with a strike
lord addict was about to say something
very slanderous against the halo of tv
series or paramount magically he gets
removed and then you come in jeff grubb
what do you have to say for this show
how's it going he's doing that
no doubt turn your mic up to tell your
microphone is paramount plus approved
paramount
[Laughter]
a little bit even more we got we got to
hear you clear we hopefully we get out
of here let me let's get in here let me
just get these these two super tests
real quick
do it real quick we got donald taco 5
the iop are the eternals who only
interfere when an even greater threat is
involved don't partake in any petty wars
they doing on twitter that is absolutely
the truth
then we have drawn tj 10 chat really
attic think about think about this
embracer group 140 studios microsoft can
make the ea games multiplat
all day
we will see okay
yeah flame real quick two dollars super
chat attic will be back with a chair
all right no doubt let's get it out
shout out to jeff grubb
how do i sound now is this any better
yeah a little better a little better a
little better a little bit more give me
a second yeah we gotta keep it clear
sounded good
no doubt but uh yeah man how you been
otherwise sir just a lot going on with
you
yeah i've been good i've been uh i've
been just kind of moving that's a big
thing here so i can't hang out too long
today i got to pack up some more but uh
we're making progress we're getting a
lot of boxes packed up so i'm feeling
pretty good about our progress no doubt
solve going through the same thing as
you yeah
yeah
yeah no doubt it's getting out of boxes
mm-hmm
no doubt
yeah it's a boxes everywhere it is uh
it's it's you know it's like we're
renting so like we got to like also kind
of try to make sure it's not in the way
but also like that's not my problem i
just got to get them packed up and move
on with my life
good to have you for a topic or two
however you want to hang so look let's
get to it man the series s making some
news this week out selling the ps5 in
japan for the first time uh series s
looks like um courtesy of limited run
games or japanese business manager who
quoted the sales figures from famitsu
for last week he said it sold six
thousand using units more than doubling
the ps5 uh two thousand nine hundred
king glassy laughing complete units for
both the physical and digital versions
of the console and they talk about
historically how xbox generally uh
struggled in the market and while
playstation has been comfortably sell in
the millions only the 360 made it to
seven figures in japan so this has been
the talk of the weekend it's been it's
been emotional for some
it's been fun for others but uh let's
start with uh lord grub man what's your
thoughts on this and while atticus comes
back out of uh paramount twitter jail
but um
what you think about it
i i think that this is these are pretty
good numbers for an xbox system in the
year 2022. like uh japan doesn't care
about home consoles all that much
anymore like the only system that really
sells there is the switch and put in
perspective like the switch regularly
selling 100 000 units each week so this
is nowhere near that but it is doing
much better than the xbox one did and i
think that's that's the right comparison
point like you're not it's probably not
going to ever do as well as the 360 did
in japan 360 had japanese made games
that people like really cared about
there and back then people played more
console games in japan like
god the 360 came out though when it
first came out there was no iphone right
there was no there wasn't the mobile
gaming was a completely different scene
it is a completely different world there
now when it comes to gaming and people
play on the go they want to be social
they want to be out and about they go
out there with their friends and they
play games on their phones and sometimes
on their switches uh so the idea that
the the xbox series s is enabling it to
sell better than the xbox one is good
it's not like
some like six thousand in a week is not
a huge number and so i think it's we can
keep these two ideas in our head at the
same time right like we're all we're
complicated people we can understand
that both these things could be true
so i think that's where i'm at where
both things are true it's pretty good
for an xbox in 2022 it's not some
magnificent number and of course the
playstation 5 number is just completely
irrelevant because it's just
that is completely limited by supply and
has nothing to do with reality no doubt
no doubt well said lord adam back how we
doing sir mike's uncensored how are we
feeling can you guys hear me yeah we got
you we got you man it was funny as soon
as you was talking slanderous you know
tvc powerball guys how much all i was
gonna say is we're gonna do a uh spoiler
cast on the halo tv show season one
careful vacation uh yeah
yeah i'm not gonna have paramount snipe
me again
it's funny you know how your mouth is
calm down bro you don't was looking at
the comment section when i left and jeff
gruff came in
people are like daddy people are like
addict just addict just looks different
[Music]
[Laughter]
a little bit of talking about this topic
about the you know xbox series s in
japan and doing well i'll sell the ps5
for one week but what's your thoughts on
it
it's good uh you know i actually i hope
that i don't think this is gonna train
like this isn't gonna be a thing where
it goes up and up and up and up and up
i think you know uh the series s uh is
more compatible to
fit into a japanese home than we have
people need to remember that you know uh
playstation's a mom my room
stop
people need to remember he said i don't
want that big thing in my house the
series x is also that silly as well sir
don't make me feel outside though
remember like my room
is like the size of a lot of like both
of them like like my room is like split
half compared to like the size the
average room is over there and that's
just because how that that's just how
they've always been like the japanese
society in general so it's just like
look like i think that this does well
because it's a smaller compact object
that they could fit into uh you know
their household a lot easier and i also
think that you know there's going to be
where if you're not doing the mobile
thing i think you're going to see a lot
more of those like screens that make it
portable
i think you're going to see more of that
going around too it's just like i'm a
huge japanese rpg person and the better
it does in japan the more
obligated some of the japanese
developers will feel to maybe i won't
miss the next three four personas and i
have to wait a decade for them
so that's all i care about i don't care
real quick just a slight diversion um
any chance grub you hear anything about
persona these days baby they're excited
over there baby something's going on we
heard anything personified we always try
to get this man in trouble everybody
let's get him in trouble
break the nba like no
yeah honestly persona feels like it's
run like it feels like segan atlas
just like there's that meme going around
where it's like they have a dart board
and then the xbox is a really small
sliver and everything else is pretty big
and they just throw it with the
blindfold
i mean that legit feels how they operate
uh they would make money if they put
those games on other systems like like
yeah xbox is one thing but they aren't
even on switch and most of the games
would sell
literally yeah yeah not even most of
them aren't even on pc they just bought
persona 4 golden like a year and a half
ago or something like that and they did
super well and now like we're just kind
of like watching our look at our watches
waiting for them to do something else
and they're still not now they are on
this like year and a half long
announcement procession where they're
like we're gonna announce a little bit
each each week or each every couple of
months and it's like the first couple
months it's like here's a wallpaper for
your phone and everyone's like goddamn
excuse me
i imagine that as we get further and
further into this announcement sort of
uh schedule that they have
part of it i mean the end is probably
going to be persona 6 almost certainly
also exclusive to playstation for who
knows what reason but in between now and
then i do think that
let him repeat it
i think persona 5 probably does finally
get announced for other platforms
between now and then that's between now
okay so these are coming so solves these
are coming yes
listen i don't think someone ever said
guys
he wants to see drastic changes
but now i thought i thought
his knees could speak for themselves
when they didn't even see it fit to
re-release the fighting game that they
released on their previous platform once
again on their new platform that's all i
have to say i listen man it's gonna be
so good
it's gonna be so good because he's been
impervious to knee bending for a minute
but it's time but your day is coming i
dig i did get it with the swipe yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i got it with your cards
but i'm
so pretty much you would say like you
think it's a good thing overall but
don't get too gassed
i i think that you know you're seeing
the growth in there just because of the
economics when it comes to like the
console itself
um but and so like jeff grubb said until
they actually start investing into that
ecosystem bringing more of their games
to their platform i think a lot of jeff
because i mean we've seen phil spencer
said in an interview not too long ago
that some of the developers look at him
like we don't even see your store your
console in our stores
so it's just like until you i think the
biggest thing that they're going to want
to see
is them investing into like a studio
over there by like because they have one
now
but i think it's going
he told me the day of the episode is
definitely coming in i think he's just
made because we beat him in halo
[Laughter]
i think the biggest thing that's going
to improve the
you know the state that xbox is on the
japanese market it's just more investing
into their marketplace because uh you
know when you put money to an ecosystem
the people are magically going to start
being unbiased towards you because
you're actually putting money into
people's pockets you open up i mean i
don't know how it is easy just like open
up studios over there but it's going to
be hard to like really come at microsoft
100 if like people are debating on
leaving other companies to work at a
studio at microsoft has because they're
making more money so you know until we
start seeing that i don't i see i think
that microsoft will be aggressive in
their terms of their wallet right
obviously it's hard to tell a company
we're not making a game on your platform
when microsoft backs up the truck and
says but are you though
but i do feel like you know you're going
to naturally see games miss xbox until
xbox
invest into the actual ecosystem of
japan no doubt no doubt lord solves
eminent needs coming but uh about the
topic about the topic or in your dreams
i'm dreaming um so like what do you
think man series as like
is it a new era the unthinkable hell
that's frozen how did this happen
listen
like grub said and like attic said i i
think
it's great for xbox right now right in
the grand scope of things it isn't a big
deal but what i will say is this and to
addict's point the s has appeal beyond
just being there on the shelf that's
cool in japan it's the fact it is the
absolute fact that when you think about
how their house homes are set up their
apartments are set up they they're gonna
gravitate to something small and if it's
something like game pass you cannot deny
the value no matter what country you
live in it's it's something that is
going to be appealing to people so for
me
you remove the conversation about the
playstation not being available that
sure that's a party but the fact of that
matter is that if the same case had been
true during the ps4 xbox generation
and the ps4 was not available you
they would not be buying xbox one s's
they would not be buying xbox
the fact is that there is appeal in this
in this in this console and this
ecosystem in a way that there hasn't
been since the 360 era it's just
not to mention they they're being more
aggressive in game pass in general over
there uh at the tokyo game show they
announced uh when uh that new what was
that game uh scarlet nexus was coming
together
like clearly they are trying to aim that
spotlight in the japanese market
yeah they definitely are so to me
it's you know will this happen
consistently no i don't have a new era
but at the same time but we have it's a
good sign though it is a good it is
definitely
spirits i don't know what's happening
when you look at the nintendo argument
right nintendo has said that they're
gonna they've sold less switches over
the past over the past year and changed
so
you know whether that means they're
winding down or on on this version of
the switch or they're looking towards
the future whatever the next switch is
whatever the case may be they've sold
less switches so there's a saturation in
the market of switching whatever the
case may be they're selling less of them
so that that leaves an opening for
something like this to happen otherwise
you're going to see the switch kick in
both of their assets every single month
and so at the end of the day i think it
just shows that there is interest in a
way that there hasn't been before and
that to me that is a that is a positive
all the way up oh king turned the case
something's about to happen i don't know
what's going on
so that's it
they said oh they snipe you because
you're about to slip
damn cake
what are they doing what's going on they
know what you're about to do
i do feel like they're off cut back off
i do feel like microsoft's more open to
spending money in japan now yeah
you know you've clearly seen them get
like massive amounts of games on the
game pass and to my knowledge yakuza's
all of them are none of them have left
game pass have they no they haven't and
they've been in there for a minute all
the final fantasies have left already
and the yakuza's in there before the
final fantasy that is true so like it's
kind of interesting like do they do they
just pay to have them on their full time
for gear going on forward that's not
generally how these things work usually
there's a time limit i'm just curious
why none of them have left yet that is
interesting let me ask you to grab
something while we wait for ken and come
back what do you feel like
how do you feel about obviously seeing
this series that's
do much better but my question is like
the series x
is it seem to be moving at that rate you
know to me that the s is is it just do
you feel like it just the compact nature
is truly the the selling point for the
series s over the x
yeah i mean i think that the series x is
a um the series x is probably also
supply limited in japan so it's like if
you are
going out and you have money in your
pocket and you want to get something
just to put like chances are they
probably have like their primary gaming
platform in japan and they are like oh
okay i'm gonna get a secondary thing
this 300 300
option is affordable compact it does
everything i needed to do and it's uh
and and it's like it's it doesn't really
feel all that like limiting and they
also are used to playing on their phones
so it's not like they're
this is what like they're thinking
next-gen all the time they're just like
i want access to the games and this is a
great way to do that now
you could say why wouldn't they just do
it through their phone and many people i
bet are considering that in japan like
just going with xbox
xbox cloud at some point in the future
but if you wanted to have a just a
native experience 300 is not that much
for especially if you're someone who
plays a lot of games like your gaming
budget like there isn't a new switch
right now to get i mean you get maybe
they already got the switch oled last
year now they're like
you know 300 for new hardware it's
exciting i think i'm just going to pick
it up and i i do think though with the
bottom line is it's available and it's
compact and it's affordable like those
three you kind of can't beat those three
things and then you know the yakuza
games that stuff does have an appeal
i also but i would i would like if
microsoft would come to me and say hey
jeff
what would i do i'd say uh get out of my
home first of all i can't give you free
advice i'm a journalist since i'm on a
show i can do it publicly and everyone
can hear it this is okay
i would say uh
don't invest too much in japan like
that's it's a market that i mean yeah
here's what you should do there are
there's a lot of talent in japan there's
a lot of people who make great games in
japan
you support them and unlock their
potential globally
that is well worth the investment and
you should be doing that i'm with that
do not do that with the purpose of like
this is going to make us big in japan i
think they've learned this lesson yeah
and honestly i think that's what's
happening right now is
they are they don't look like they are
trying to force it in japan and they're
just kind of getting success regardless
now success on an xbox live
yeah
we all know how to make levels
yeah yeah
completely is this idea and it's an
antiquated idea that kids be successful
in japan you need to bring japanese
games to japan necessarily whereas the
the global appeal
japan as a market has shrunk so much
that it's the global approval of these
games the fact that people still care
about you know classic jrpgs around the
world that's what matters and i don't
know why this this there's still this
sort of thinking that it has to be
successful necessarily in japan for it
to be successful elsewhere and to invest
money in it elsewhere it's just not the
case anymore
it just isn't like you know
i do i do personally i feel like they
are being aggressive i kind of disagree
with that because
they uh you know you see them be more
active in the tokyo game show you're
seeing them uh you know i think they
said what a thousand projects and id at
xbox that they're doing with japanese
developers but i i disagree with that
but i i do think that the prime example
of this isn't to grow in the japanese
market it's to make sure that yeah it's
to make sure that they get these games
on their platform and nothing's auto
because nothing's auto skip because
these people that are working on these
indie games they're not going to work
there forever
sooner or
you know later they're like periodically
they are making it to where when these
people do leave when they start their
own companies it's not such a negative
stigma to work with microsoft king is
invoking the fraud alert on all of us so
i would love to hear
what
he's been patient he's back after being
sniped your thoughts
xbox in japan
yo i am so sick and tired of these
beating and bruised xbox fans
listen listen they've been out selling
playstation for a minute now
and it just happened
listen listen listen and it just
happened to reach the land of the rising
sun right now
oh the news got over though okay
so i don't care about see i don't i
don't subscribe to what jeff is saying
oh my god you know because you know
playstation has a shortage that's why
the xbox is selling hell no oh really
hell do you know why when i go inside
the store and they tell me they don't
got a samsung i'm not buying a tcl
it ain't happening it ain't nothing you
can do to get me to get something i
don't want news is going out getting
what they want they saw a little man
they was like yo that fit in my house
the game's just like that let me put
this in the house because it's nice and
small yo i saw a dude with a screen on
it let me throw that screen they they
are tricking out the little little mix
no man it's moving out here he's just a
little bit
the little man is all natty in the house
the reason why
the playstation can't be in there
because it's an extra dependent all
right you gotta have a bed you gotta
have a refrigerator for it you gotta
it's it's it's too big for the market
all right so shout out to to to
everybody jason ronald and the team yeah
the engineer salute
i told you it's gonna be a two-prong
approach yes they were gonna pin them in
he's gonna have the big joint and i had
a little joint to fit all over the place
and then the clouds just coming in the
cloud it's just the extra little sauce a
little sprinkle of the sauce so just
like jeff is saying see because
them going to cloud doesn't
explain why the series has to sell it
right right it doesn't it's selling
because it's dope and we ain't gonna sit
here and say oh no you know we're gonna
temper our expectations
you know this is this is just you know
microsoft right now
no it's not we win so
this is how it's going to the wall will
be won now this is the beginning
every month
right that's what we do i don't think
it's a logical thing to say yo let's see
a couple months and see no yeah i mean
it is one week
there's no going back
and it will go up to the right forever
[Laughter]
we got to live in it now we gotta live
with the vote that's it we'll never know
but what we did though
you know it's funny the moment like if
this comes up and you know obviously if
it doesn't do this well like next month
and we bring it up kids were like it was
japan what did you expect
because you know what what i'm going to
say is oh they made some playstations
available
you can spin it anywhere you like
how i don't expect how you like to spin
it
today because these dudes is acting up i
had to get some defense force for these
dudes okay listen man
microsoft doesn't do this much but i've
seen a trend
right uh medic credit
uh you know uh publisher of the year
uh i've seen uh them launch in the
second half of the year when the first
half of last year was dry and they still
get that oculate
you know um
they're doing things
yeah
yeah they're doing things in a manner
that is different and unorthodox they're
doing this without a lot of first party
games that is true
all right so
imagine when they boys show up
that's the problem i think i think
you're seeing even the success with like
selling a couple mpds selling good in
japan this is strictly off game passes
back
i mean it's a digital console
digital console it makes sense
that little that little console
is appealing to them yes that's what
happens so you walk in the store it's
appealing it looks nice it fits your
decor it fits your situation you're not
going to get something that you know you
got to get you got to pay child support
it's not necessary so i don't care what
anybody say it's it's it's selling
because it's appealing nobody's going to
force anybody to get anything and this
is this is more to come because what
happens next month
don't wanna see me nobody wanna see me
next month if they outsell them again in
japan next month
so you seem pretty confident
i'm always confident i'm always
confident i always know so what what
what what
you gotta look like for you to do it
what's it gotta look like for you what a
guy look like the sun will shine on a
dog's butt
at some point
[Music]
he always wants these i don't know
what's up with this dude um
king called for
you know how i just dismiss you right
you're dismissed
let's let's let's let's do this right
let's do it let's just see it for what
it is
it's a a superior product that's in
demand that's inside their land and
that's the scary part about it right
that's the scary part
and they're out selling them over there
where's these playstations selling like
this they're not selling this right yeah
they just are struggling to make them
period yeah it's not available right
they're not available anyway
took that three billion dollars and
didn't buy bungie and money
more places i mean
he's really not wrong there they didn't
have that money and they're investing in
other places so clearly that that money
it's it's not that linear like you could
take that money and try to make chips it
would take years
it would just take forever yeah but
microsoft spent their money and it
seemed like they it is that linear when
they did it
that's that's the claim i don't i don't
know i think that the uh the yields on
the xbox chips are actually just better
better better design they're just better
designed
i
from a cooling situation to everything
all around the board it's just a better
yield over here
[Laughter]
our yields look nicer i will say that
maybe it's not is maybe it's not as much
on
you know microsoft paying for something
but they have that xbox series s to fall
back on right for sure
because you know it's easier to make
that i would assume than that oh yes
yeah i'll jump in this is hilarious um
yeah look it was funny to me you know i
thought this was it was definitely one
of those wow hell did freeze over there
okay like what i would i was really
blown away by this that yes we know it's
one week we know we're not getting too
crazy that's a loss though
for xbox this is japan this is japan
this is a lot this is a lot now
over there they usually sell like 120 a
week or something like that yeah like
that something happened something listen
you know
maybe it is the the the form factor
combined with the game pass effect
combined with the fact kind of what
grubby's saying like 4k tvs are not from
my understanding like a huge thing you
know over there and you know if you have
a 1080p slash 1440p device that is small
and it's visually appealing and it has
this value i mean like i will give king
this you know
people have this thing you know just
because it's there right you people are
going to buy because the other thing's
not there and that's the one you got to
want it so what it's showing is the
stock that they have is little or
whatever the size it is it's going so
that to me that's a positive sign and
i'm with softview look i don't think
their mission is to come in like this is
it we're putting the flag down we're
dominating this region it's a full
assault i think it's kind of online what
solver and grub is saying in a sense
like you know
i think what you want to do is make it
appealing to that next generation of
developers that next generation almost
like a recruiting system for yourself
and then now you don't miss out on games
in the region you just have that
presence there but the question i want
to ask you all for some fun because
historically obviously it's a big deal
for xbox
and the pantheon is 360 right 360 was
kind of like the lead over there and
then i believe it's ogx box we have xbox
one which now in this short time series
s is already here whatever the 100 000
or whatever it is total um units in
japan so my question is in this
generation i'll start with you grub
where do you think the series consoles
as a whole y'all gonna like the poll is
gonna end up at as far as will it beat
the 360 or do you just have it you know
maybe just going over the um og xbox
yeah
it's difficult to get over the ogx box
and it seems like the momentum is there
and i yeah i agree with kingdom people
have to want this this is this is a
system that um
it has its own appeal for
intrinsic reasons it's it's not about
like oh comparing to other things in the
market um and that is you can't you
can't buy that you can't force that you
have to earn it and they they earned it
with this system and that is something
they can
ride and and build on and i i just think
the 360 is um probably a milestone that
is just too far because of the way this
this does have to do with reality of the
market and how people have changed how
they consume games in japan and the
playstation 4 was all like a good system
that everyone loved and that system
didn't sell very well in japan i think
the 360 almost almost outsold that thing
not exactly but it got pretty close um
when you compare it from one generation
to the next so it's like the way they
are consuming games is just completely
different so
this system selling 6 000 units this
week
is a sign that they they are way out
performing expectations way ahead of the
curve and to me it's just nothing but
good signs but it's not going to outsell
the 360. i don't think 360 peterborough
error okay game has changed attic what
do you think will it be the goat xbox
system
i just got a quick question for jeff
real quick
uh do you think that the markets just
drastically change enough where they
cannot realistically ever beat the 360
or do you think there's stuff they can
do to
make the odds better in their favor
i mean they could probably do some
things to make dots better in the favor
but i think we're talking about
percentage points we're talking about
you know five percent here and there
gain over time uh i think for the most
part
the market has changed enough that they
would that the 360 is going to be this
thing that they're never going to be
able to replicate again in japan because
the people have changed too much
more on the team no doubt added adding
big overall i i i'd agree like here's
the thing like
at the end of the day
it seems like the japanese markets went
almost entirely to a
a mobile aspect now i don't know if they
would i think microsoft has gave up on
selling well there i think they keep
relations up for the western market and
i think that's the x cloud
is what they're that they don't care if
they're going to sell you a console over
there at this point microsoft is trying
to make a service to sell you games over
there
uh and i think that's their their
primary obviously they're going to try
to do what they can to sell over there
because if they do nothing then they're
never going to sell them anything over
there
uh so i think that is their prime goal
now as far as beating the 360 over there
what did they what did it be on the 360
over there um as far as the unit sales
as far as them looks like 360 had over 1
million 600 thousand units looks like
yeah one point six million yeah
according to games
and xbox 474 000 the og
it just depends on how hard they go in
game pass that they start being very
aggressive and trying to get a lot of
these games third party like uh you know
if they make another persona if they not
only get that in the game
into uh xbox day and date but they try
to get that in game pass as well like
enough of those games i feel like could
entice a lot of the japanese market to
buying it but at the end of the day like
i don't know if they have the relations
and they're willing to spend that kind
of money to do anything like that like
there's only so much they can do as a
western company in the eastern
in the eastern part of the world so i
just i i don't know enough about like
relations and stuff like that to know if
that's something realistically they can
do no don't solve quickly what do you
think overall
the pantheon of xbox consoles where will
it land yeah i think because of the the
size of the the series s yeah i think
it's going to come up second place
behind the 360 at some point but i agree
with addict 100 like i i think the
ultimate play is at cloud and game pass
and i think if that moves the needle i
think when we talk about
the most popular sort of xbox generation
ever in japan it could definitely be
this one just because of the
proliferation of game pass no doubt to
me that's it
quickly will the dominus rise to the
greatest xbox executive and do the
unthinkable defeat peter boy in the
region if
if like on the rail if phil spencer is
able to do that
like that's crazy this series console is
going to go down in oh xbox they sniped
them
as soon as he said it
i feel like he's doing this on purpose
i'm not you probably got another camera
app open that's for fighting for yeah
fighting
of
across the sky because
at no point in time do i think that
they're going to stop their level of
growth they're going to surpass the 360.
oh and
and and everybody's sitting there like
oh i don't think so yeah i do think so i
definitely think so i definitely think
when this joint has 200 dollars
and it's a snatch and grab when you run
inside the store call of duty package
it's it's it's a wrap it's literally a
wrap i don't care what how i told people
before i don't think just does the
japanese market play like those type of
games i'm talking about overall i'm
talking about in in his totality i'm
talking about talking about i'm talking
about europe and i'm talking about in
japan i'm talking about this will this
series consoles will be the definitive
console when it comes to xbox this is
going to be legendary and they're going
to start doing it and when it hits 200 i
don't care what region you win
you won't walk in the store that's when
you can't deny it that's when yeah three
hundred dollars you like i don't know
two hundred dollars you walk in and
you're walking out but if you care about
it you're gonna get it here's where i
push back a little bit king watch back
if you like you can
you can make the price point two hundred
dollars in full filling here in the
western states because i feel like they
got a lot of western games
but as far as like others
other regions of the world you gotta
have the games that appeal to that
market before they go why would they
spend money on a console if they don't
have the games in the genres that they
like sure some of them will like like
there's a lot of people like especially
overwatch what happened i know that
there's six thousand people right now
this is
last week it's the start of a generation
you can answer that question it takes a
bit
game pass on xbox last week that six
thousand people woke up and said it was
it was just that they they hijacked the
shipment of playstation
say whatever you want to see are you
saying that mike is soft with a fast
enough
thousand people woke up and voted with
their wallet
what happens when six thousand more wake
up
you know there's a lot of people over
there
is the one on switch it's a it's a
japanese only game that i guess people
really love that game but
yeah that's all they have okay
here's the thing king
like we gotta move up in yeah i know one
more week of good sales doesn't make up
the amount of money in the matter
of a new era
tell me
on why six thousand people woke up and
brought a series asked
i want to know the answer but i'm gonna
keep
let's be real here we
was that a whole month they sold six
thousand units
it was wait one week a week okay one
week crazy
oh my god
what type what happened was it a special
promotion did it was it especially
okay
i'm not saying that they're not going to
do well i'm not saying that i'm saying
that in order to do what you're saying
they have to consistently keep that
momentum and even
without trying i don't know why they got
up and brought it that's all i'm saying
i'm just saying we don't have a metric
to say the reason why nothing special
happened last week that made 6 000
people wake up but y'all keep telling me
calm down like why should i calm down
when i don't worry why six thousand
people woke up and i don't know if six
thousand people will wake up tomorrow
and go do it again so i don't know
because you know what think about it
this way right those six thousand people
told their friends right over more than
friends right friends
and if they tell your friends
um yo we game share what your game share
how did that work
what have they already sold in overall
japan up to a thousand another one this
week
you don't know that well i get what
you're saying
like i get like it's like i said like
they're they're strictly selling xboxes
right now off off of the value of game
pass and once they get more games it's
going to pick up because more people are
going to see more value in game pass
because it's got good games but all i'm
telling you is when you're missing stuff
like final fantasy vii persona
what it didn't stop them from selling
the six thousand this is what i'm trying
did they sell six thousand last week
what did they sell last year
six thousand the week before they're
just waking up come on stop playing
are still only just over 200 000 right
now according to famitsu look all i will
say is this is absolutely hilarious um i
do feel the thing that i find funny jeff
i have to admit is that there are there
is a section of gamers that are very
upset about this they don't want king to
be happy they don't like there's any
news and it's like shut up yeah
you got it okay king you want to be
happy uh it sold 10 000 last week
[Applause]
so it's so lesson
here's the thing the reason it was a big
deal this week is because the
playstation 5 was at like 46 000 last
week and then
and then this week it was like two
thousand there was zero it's a
revolution
exactly all the people who realized it
was like you know what this thing is too
big do they got the return
i'm betting 6 000 return their
playstations oh my god now you know now
you know the metrics
that's what happened last week they said
this thing is too big for the house and
i got to play an extra how are you
excited for performing worse how are you
excited
[Laughter]
oh it takes a village
it's one of those situations for kids
anyway look it is interesting they're
selling out this dog we'll see how this
we'll chart this and i know attic will
be ready
if the dumpers are back
and you are down playing the six in the
week before they sold 10.
next week
so that's week if they say if they sell
over 50 000 units next month i will bend
the needle oh
okay we're doing it thousand
fifty thousand or something that he just
offered do you wanna sell your needs
that's the one you i don't care i'll
tell you no no no
no no he said he said month he said
month though
it's gonna be four weeks that'd be four
weeks jeff if he wanna send look how
comfortable he is until he gets put in
that spot
i'm not betting on them
but what happened wait wait wait
what are you gonna talk about
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he was being
right now because i said america he was
like ah nah man you know what they've
been doing it
let's jump over the ps plus and talk
about ea because that's new we don't
want to hear what yeah we got to hear
yeah we got to max somebody's time that
is correct
let's get it after jeff i know jeff
can't stay right okay okay we'll do the
super chats after okay no doubt
[Laughter]
yeah so basically ea is trying to sell
right now according to reports looks
like um those close to uh came quite
close to merging with nbc universal
according to puck's industry sources
comcast ceo brian roberts considered
handing control of nbc universal over to
ea ceo andrew wilson in a deal that
would have seen the two companies form
an entertainment giant but the
negotiations eventually stalled when the
two parties couldn't settle on a price
shout out to jeff keagley he also said
that um
the story that ea also had talks with
disney apple and amazon so let's get
this attic time i'll let you set it up
and uh i know you want to bring this to
the to the table man
i think it's just interesting i think
microsoft is kind of like domino effect
all buying all these companies probably
but that is the really open
i think if the bethesda thing don't
happen bungie doesn't sell activision
doesn't sell because i feel like at that
point these companies felt like they
were too big to be purchased
well maybe not bungee bungee uh you know
they're just one game a very successful
game but not like a massive publisher
like that but i feel like microsoft has
has opened up pandora's box and i'm very
curious to see like
after if ea does merge with someone it
looks like it's not a matter of if uh
they do its win i'm kind of curious if
like ubisoft don't try to merge with
someone and then you know you see like a
drastic
change in how these giant publishers
handle stuff because they're for the
most part i think you can really
realistically say that a lot of these
big publishers dropped the ball in one
shape or form uh in terms of their games
like ea just lost the fifa license
didn't they
uh you know when the ea
got rid of the fear
they said get
foh yeah
[Laughter]
so it's just interesting like i'm very
interested especially to hear what uh
jeff grubb has to say about that like do
you think that
all these companies are slowly going to
start selling themselves to bigger
entities
yes in like the next five years yes i
mean what i heard after the activation
deal was that all these companies were
looking at all of their options
immediately there were panicked meetings
immediately ea was one of those
companies for sure um
there are people with these companies
whose jobs it is
to
assess the landscape for possible
mergers and acquisitions and to to be
acquired and they need to um kind of
like get the landscape and they need to
understand like who is out there that
could be a potential partner so i'm not
surprised at all to hear that they
talked to disney and apple they probably
talk to everybody and they put together
okay here's the reality of the situation
here are the numbers we're hearing
initially um where does this position us
in terms of like how we should be like
what should be our attack strategy those
meetings happen to every single company
it happened at ubisoft it happened at ea
happened
everywhere um
that list of
names is not even like the full list
that i've heard i've heard some other
names that i can't say because i got
told off the record i can say that there
are there are more names now microsoft
is not one of those i don't think that's
a big surprise to anybody because of the
deal that has ongoing with that mission
they're just trying to upset that
yes hitting activision is more important
than like trying to be involved in any
of these other deals they want that
activision deal to go through that's way
more important that's way more valuable
um
the the trouble is that like there's no
like real natural partners for a lot of
these big companies like ubisoft
especially is in this weird situation
where
um they yes they make a lot of money but
they employ way more people than most
other companies like they have like
double the number of employees of
something like ea yeah and yet their
their market capitalization is a
fraction of yeah they're like like six
seven eight billion dollars market
capitalization compared to eas like 35
40 billion
market capitalization and yet they have
twice as many employees that is
right for what they are going to talk
about now which is private equity and
media that's probably going to mean
they're going to come in they're going
to chop shop a bunch of jobs they are
going to make this lean and mean and
then try to sell again at that point and
that's kind of i think it seems like
ubisoft needs to go through that process
if they want to be involved in any of
these deals um yeah go ahead i had a
quick question before you interrupt
cause you talk about lean and mean hold
on what's good i gotta do what else if i
forget you talk about leader meaning
trimming
we're seeing this kind of behavior with
square enix it's literally okay
yeah absolutely so so
now that they're kind of making
themselves a little bit more attractive
for a bit possible you know do you cut
the [ __ ] you don't want
like do do you think that it potentially
could happen with one of the students
baby being a microsoft facility
yeah i mean that's i think that's the
entire reason they're doing everything
over at square enix right now they are
look i mean the things they got rid of
were the things that don't look good on
a profit and loss page on a spreadsheet
where it's like what are the things that
make us the highest profit margin well
not those things then get out of here
they got rid of those things and now
just by doing that they look like a more
profitable company they're not
necessarily a more profitable company
but they look like one and that is
and that's what people like when they
when the the accountants are looking at
this they're like well we need to
project out into the future and so now
that bigger number is what the number
we're going to work from because it's a
bigger profit margin number and we can
project them being worth this much and
making this much money for us if we
invest this much and that really helps
that is i think that's 100 what they are
doing i think all these companies are
doing exactly that um
so like do do they all get acquired or
merge or something in the next five
years i i think so i think that they
like the landscape is
the reality is that the video gaming
publisher landscape has actually been
pretty stagnant for what it what it was
for a pretty long time a long time yeah
it's kind of been due for a lot of these
shake-ups where
bigger companies come in and they like
they spot the value in here and so
they're like okay
we're going to come in and acquire stuff
and then what that does is that
fertilizes the ground now there's more
space for the people who are at these
companies getting acquired to take their
money and go start their own studios
that are smaller that will one day 10 15
years from now those will be the ones
getting acquired that's the way the
process is supposed to work and it
hasn't really for quite some time and
now microsoft is like proving that
there's value in this stuff and and
everyone else is looking around like oh
god we just went through a pandemic
where our parks and our movies and our
our public you know our you know our
public uh entertainment stuff all that
stuff was worthless and video games
would have been really nice to have
video games and they all kind of came to
the same realization at the same time so
yeah the the the values there they're
beginning to act and we are we're at the
beginning of a process of sort of
renewal in gaming and uh creating an
opportunity where a lot of these
companies can spin off and create a
million other companies yeah and i
actually feel like you're going to see
once these companies like you said start
merging you're going to see companies
like devolver digital team 17 like
they're not gonna have as much
competition going after like these these
these double-a games and i think they'll
eventually start like dabbling their
their their toes in the triple-a market
and then yeah i mean they're public
companies they got to grow yeah they
gotta grow now so they're going to do
bigger and bigger and bigger stuff every
single time now every year going forward
bigger and bigger and then before you
know it they're going to take the mantle
that the eas and the ubisoft left when
they merge with other companies
that's right it's interesting now we got
group here still want to ask another
question where do you fit we see ea you
know kind of actively shopping you know
where do we see wb in all this with
discovery and you know that's another
point of contention being king half
and you know but i'm just curious like
where do you see them standing out
because obviously i call leading the
witness i am leader i am leading i am
biased i am trying to push my narrative
against king yes um so my thing is uh
specifically
even if without the whole shebang so to
speak where it's like uh you know like
never
[Laughter]
in general so where do you think just
you know you'll feel as if you want to
break break nda or tell anything be feel
free
yeah well let me know here's here's a
little bit of like insider informed
information um
let's so let's look at an example there
was a company at wb uh monolith i
believe that made the lord of the rings
games right yes and and they were like
yeah great studio right so if you wanted
to make a game like that what would you
do you go by that studio right no that's
not what ea did he just said hey we'll
start a new studio you come work for us
and that's a bunch of the key people at
monolith did they left they go work for
ea now and
why do you do that because well we're
not gonna get the ip if we go by
monolith and so it doesn't make it
doesn't make any financial sense it is
you are buying liabilities now there is
one exception to this yes
it is netherrealm
that could almost certainly come along
but
yeah i mean they haven't sold yet why i
mean i think i think wb i think um
discovery or whatever that conglomerate
is that actually owns all that stuff
there it's still like well maybe we do
want to keep mortal kombat ip it's like
no you can't if you're selling
netherrealm you have to sell give it up
give up the stickers
this is a game property it makes makes
way more money as a game than it does as
a movie let's be real here so
very attractive for strangers
i think it's going to determine how
harry potter wonder woman do his video
games and if those do well
oh wow yeah if those do well i have a
feeling um
discover
i feel like if discover sees good
results in harry potter good results and
these ips that are out right now being
developed suicide squad i think you're
going to eventually see them okay maybe
gaming is something we need to stick
into
but i do feel like i do feel like in the
flip side that those games don't do well
financially and they don't give
discovery
the uh the type of success that they
feel like they deserve in that genre or
that gaming industry in general you're
going to see a flash sale go on where
they're like just taking it
a sweetheart deal
where where like ip licensing
is included almost at cost without
without without ongoing fees where it's
like as long as you're making new games
every couple of years you get to keep
the ip uh sort of like those old marvel
marvel licensing deals worked and and
kind of like if if that's not going to
happen i don't know how much like uh
discovery would like have or discover
whatever it is has the stomach for that
um it just seems very far-fetched that
any company would see the value in
bringing on a liability of hiring
literally thousands of new people that
you have to now pay you know their their
wages and their benefits and then you
also have to go out and pay the license
and i p it is something that doesn't
make a lot of sense in most
cases not to mention it's not a gaming
company too it's not a gaming company
they're not gonna
they're not gonna do that
they can have being used in existing
things
listen you know
all i want jeff to do is just give
people the hiyachi
listen so big like like my bad brother
one bad mother shout out to xbox era so
basically what greg grumman said you
know microsoft and netherrealm just a
matter of time just when you know and
you've just stayed i'm so glad you broke
the story here on iop that it's just
only a matter of listening and i'm going
to be tuned in on june 12th because jeff
jeffrey said here first show
oh my god oh my god
totally professional totally
professional that jeff go write 10
articles you heard it here first
we need the traffic just make sure you
highlight on the iron lord's podcast
make sure you give us a little views on
that
exclusive
you see they keep you guys closer
i think an expensive thing that game
makes a ton of money it is such a world
beater in terms of like
you you oh yeah it's very important that
are probably as profitable as mortal
kombat so that's probably why it's been
so hard to even sell even if they do
want to sell it yeah i'm gonna help you
in your personal opinion jeff do you
think netherrealm is something that
microsoft should look at if they if they
could get the articles right now because
it's exactly the right kind of game
it's exactly the right kind of game that
fits with games
clip it clip it it's official it's
happening 2 12. i'm tuning in thank you
jeff man
june listening on june 12th i'll be at
the end of the show
that's all we got
oh man don't let what's his name jump on
stage oh man let me stop not let me jump
on stage and say listen we'll be coming
to game pass day
you know
king would be so extra if if microsoft
ever came out and said that netherrealm
isn't in the type of studio though oh
yeah we'd never get into it
anyway solve any more questions for
grabbing this topic or before we move on
no no man i i think it's it's
interesting that you know it's like he's
i think the perfect sort of way to look
at this is to say is
this consolidation is happening now it's
kind of like just it's kind of the
natural evolution of things where these
big these big companies are going to
come together to be even bigger and then
that makes way to to create a new aaa
space from the smaller and i actually
feel like we need it i think it's the
nature of it it's going to happen again
as well so i mean what games are ea next
division they they're not making they
don't make games anymore they make it
that's what i'm saying like
we need to be like honestly it sounds
weird but we need embracer like we need
an embracer to be like i believe in
triple a games exactly right we're
making 200 we're making 25 aaa games
well i hope they're really doing that
and and because that is like a multi
like a multiple of how many triple a
games ea and activision combined have
made in the last several years yeah i
mean it's they just don't believe in it
anymore and that that's okay time to
cash out yeah let's get let's create
space for something new there needs to
be a redefinition of that space yeah
only thing that's why okay
i was just gonna say that's why i was so
open to microsoft buying activision
because like besides all the you know
personal stuff going over there like
game wise
like they got too comfortable let's just
keep making these type of formulas
because we know it's and you know
microsoft's going to do the same thing
but hopefully if under leadership they
might take a little bit more risk in
terms of what they want game pass frees
them up to do to take those risks that's
the whole idea of game pass is the game
doesn't have to be a 12 million seller
on its own
as long as it is contributing to this
overall thing that everyone can buy into
in game pass so yeah like it just makes
it work better and that's that's that's
exciting on its own and then then we
have this whole thing of now there's
space in the market for our new aaa
publisher to grow yeah yeah my only
thing i wanted to add just for reference
to ea was just um selfishly i just want
to know where respawn goes i'm such a
response fanboy and shout out to vince
of course i thought boy patrick wren who
was at 343 who's now over they was on
ilp before and i'm dying to see what
those guys cook up and you know i got to
be honest my only concern is you know
the names we're hearing
not obviously microsoft is completely in
in bed with this activision thing you
know they have to finalize that deal
it's all hands on deck sony we don't
know if that's in the range or even of
interest you know for them and then when
you hear the amazons and you know and
the 10 cents you know let's get a little
a little concerned you know just as far
as the commitment to gaming is just my
only thing but yeah we got to see what's
going on it is it is the market is i'm
with you so the market is transforming
before our very odds and our traditional
way of thinking is just gonna is going
to have to change because this is where
it's going
and cog i actually feel like the more
the studio the more these big publishers
have bought the remaining big ones like
they're just naturally going to feel
like they're worth more and they're
going to try to sell for more so
you see your activision being bought for
70 billion dollars ea's over like how
much can we get for us
yo the fact that it was close to nbc
universal houses wow that's crazy yeah
that's we like that's like a strange
bedfellow like because it's like and it
was like the top was like andrew wilson
would be the ceo of this new company
that's like
okay how does that and then maybe it's
like okay they start making movies and
shows based on all their stuff
if anything that shows npcs they're
interested in getting into the gaming
market i want to know like if how much
ea priced itself out
like well how crazy did they get with
the number that everybody was like you
know what i mean that's the whole like
the part of that panic was as soon as uh
like that deal went through like
remember where ea was at right at that
moment they were just coming off a
really disastrous battlefield launch and
they were like
we we cannot battlefield cannot be our
our marquee thing what are we going to
do and they're like uh point to respawn
point apex legends like pointed that and
that's what they did and they started
running a bunch of commercials and when
they did their uh conference call with
the investors they're like apex legends
is doing great what the hell you talk
about battlefield
their stock price went up and it was
like so they're doing everything they
can to make themselves appear as
valuable as possible because they when
they have these conversations they they
really believe that they should be sold
for quite some like a pretty huge number
uh probably on
on par if not just like just behind what
activision went for yeah that's a lot
it's a lot of money anyways moving on
scrub let me know how much time you got
because i definitely want to be honest
i'm probably going to head out in the
next 10 minutes or so if you want to get
a couple more questions in i'm happy
with that let's get one more topic then
we'll do super chats after that okay so
you want to do so uh y'all want to do
which order which i want i want to give
them the um the bungee joint or you want
to give them the playstation plus line
up which i want they leave it up
playstation plus line up all right
playstation plans for 200. we're going
to do it to jeopardy
that was so funny
when i saw that i was like i don't even
care i was like i'm going to post in the
chat because yeah
i'm still in this you got to know right
now in jeopardy
yeah yeah that's what i got my guy that
sets it up i'll make sure that he gets
you all the information oh please do it
we got to do that's so much fun but you
you guys should come on and be a guest
because
each month so you guys come on next
month i meet someone so you know you
guys choose your champion yes and you
send them over and go down we might be
on there
what do they want to do
as long as it's not retro stuff
oh
uh yes off we got a playstation plus to
revamp right we got some lineups we got
some games yeah so the the lineup for
the new revamp playstation plus that's
going to be coming out uh in june over
here is actually out today
in other parts of the world i believe
it's either today or it was the pat in
the past couple of days so uh we we're
gonna be getting it later uh in june
yeah they announced uh some of the games
that were coming to these tiers and uh
i don't know there's been sort of mixed
reaction to it i think a lot of people
thought there would be a lot more games
from the onset um obviously the things
that are that
when you look at the middle tier of the
of of the ps plus sort of uh tier system
now that's where the vast majority of
the games are that's where you're gonna
get your ps4 games and your ps5 five
games and the library there is pretty
robust especially if you have not played
these games or got into these games in
any way shape or form
um now when you look at the top tier
which is the one that includes the demos
which includes access to uh old school
games like ps1 and psp games
some remastered games in the form of
some ps2 games and mps one game i
believe
um and ps3 games that are accessible
through the cloud that's where sort of
the conversation starts to change and
it's more about this is despite the fact
that they're saying this is just the
initial batch of of games that we're
announcing it still feels like it's very
very thin
um so
it's it's just kind of again i'm not
going to continue to belabor the point
this is that this doesn't feel like it's
competing with game pass in any way
shape or form at the same time when you
look at the price of this particular
tier and you see what you're getting so
far
um
especially when you know they have a lot
of games that belong to them that you it
seems like could easily go into this
like legacy stuff legacy stuff that
could easily go into day one um it just
feels weird for it to be this limited so
i honestly don't know what their
dedication to this is and i think
ultimately that's the thing
what is their dedication to this service
in the long term i mean i'm in it again
for at least a year to see kind of how
it progresses you know game pass when it
first started wasn't the greatest that
is true in fact look at where it is in
fairness so uh what do you guys think
about this because i think the coolest
thing to come out of what i've seen out
of this top tier is that some old school
playstation one game specifically siphon
filter was talked about are going to get
trophy support and trophy support for a
lot of people is is big on the
playstation side um so
yeah what do you guys think about this
do you think it's it's kind of do you
think it's underwhelming do you think we
really get more stuff do you think and
there's something i'd like to ask jeff
uh
is is there any truth to this sort of
rumor that they're actually working hard
to try to figure out how to get to
how to get you native playstation 3 oh
please
yeah so that i i mean the last i heard
is they are working on it i don't know
if i would describe it as working hard i
think they were kind of
looking into it yeah they got some
people like it's the basement team
working on it but right it feels like
the kind of thing we're like like it
worked on it but here's your budget man
like let's be real um and i think so i
think there's a chance that yeah maybe a
moment from day to day looking at the
dollar bill
maybe early next year maybe they come
back with something i i mean i know that
they are interested in trying to make
that happen but um
i think the reality comes down to does
they do they think that is necessary to
keep people subscribed and a lot of that
will come down to
um you know the
like what is the percentage growth from
like people who are on ps plus basic
that now upgrade i think there's
probably going to be a pretty good
number that do that and don't really
think too much about how the things will
work in the background i think most
people are just going to be like i see a
game on the list i'm not gonna really
think about how it works that's cool
i'll just go i'm just gonna play it um
i i i think that this overall is pretty
underwhelming but also i'm uh i'm still
gonna subscribe on day one because i'm a
sucker so it's like
and then i think if you are someone who
hasn't played a lot of these games
especially the list of ps4 games right
um if you're someone who hasn't played a
lot of those this is actually a pretty
good deal yes and you are in a
completely different camp and then for
you it's a good deal go for it it's
underwhelming for me good deal for you
we're both going to subscribe well
that's a win for sony so that's kind of
how i'm looking at it absolutely
absolutely let's get on attic man where
you at with this uh playstation plus
list revamp how's it looking for you
i actually think it is a comp a good
competitive thing to gain fast uh the
only thing that's really missing is the
day-to-day games that's a huge thing
don't get me wrong but i feel like what
game pass has done is it gives people
that are coming into the platform a
library of gains for a low monthly cost
and i think this does it very well uh
you know and it's like i said like we
literally just to switch away from sony
putting their games on to that service i
think the you know if they if if gamepad
starts the value of game parts starts
making them lose market value to the
point where they feel like
not doing it is costing them more money
than having games being sold for a full
retail seventy dollar price uh day i
feel like that's when they hit that
switch but as far as this i mean you
look at that list it has good games and
if you're coming off the thing that we
need to start start realizing is there
is generations like my brother
generations below people are coming into
games in the masses every year
and they're trying to get them to just
as much as they're trying to keep the
kings happy the the cognitos the addicts
happy they're trying to get the new
people coming into uh the gaming
industry in general and this is one of
those things where you could buy
playstation five you could subscribe to
whatever the essential premiere creature
i don't know what they're called but you
can get that second tier and you're good
for a couple months you have plenty of
plot to play and i think that's what
that's what brings the value of game
pass
to its fort frump and i think that's
what sells that sure the games coming in
game pass day and date does well last
year you've seen that with psychonauts
wasteland i don't know if waistline was
out last year but you guys get what i'm
saying you're seeing that with
playstation where sure not all of their
games on there but if you ain't played
god of war last gen you're getting a
playstation you're like yo what's this
god of war they're gonna get that what
that does too is that promotes ragnarok
people are playing god of war yo let me
try ragnarok oh it's 70 dollars i like
the first one i'll give them the money
and i think it's it's got a lot of
things it's just at the end of the day
it's it's not good competition but it is
decent competition for game pass
no doubt king where are you at with the
playstation plus
lineup reveal
um
i was with game pass when they didn't
have anything right
all right so i look at that and i'm like
all right that's what's up um anything
that can get me to play my playstation
hell yeah i'm all for it uh 120 for the
year i'll pay it i'm not going to let
them you know uh you know do
i already broke down finances on it um
i see the value in it okay because
there's a couple of games in there that
if i do the price
to the the cost to
purchase those games i don't care if
they you know went down to value i'll go
at uh the initial retail price of
certain games that i saw that's in there
if i go to that part those games that
i'm interested in 120 dollars is as
peanuts to what i see the value in it
right so i'm gonna get it i'm going to
go play those games and i'm going to
hope that day and date does happen um i
can't
champion a service for them to fix a
service and you know they rebrand
playstation now and playstation plus all
right i can't champion something and
want them to do something without
supporting it for it to happen you have
to go to some place you have to plant
the seeds in order to see change you
have to tend to soil you have to be
there
so if i'm a vocal uh
uh proprietor of of what they're what
they're offering
then it might change
now attic is right
game pass
has a lot to do with this rebranding and
them going in the games of service uh
model and you know talking that stuff
game pass is pushing that forward so
we're going to see growth in sony sector
i honestly
believe that at some point in time when
they get a little bit more studios and
they can release at a decent cadence
that they would do day and date it's not
cost effective for them to do day and
date where they won't see the value in
churning out a certain amount of games
at a certain amount of time microsoft
can do that with all the studios and
stuff that they do have in the games
that they do have in slate so it's going
to happen um i think you'll probably see
something like a disney plus type of
thing where as the game comes out in the
movie theater uh um
60 days out and then the game will come
out on the playstation plus platform or
like tears rescue rangers just came out
day one right exactly but that's not
that wasn't a game that's not uh even a
pixar it's not like just these well the
animation studios it's something below i
think there's gonna be a lot of that
coming out of the game where it's like
playstation is like this is a mid-tier
it's a double-a and and we're going to
fill in the gap
with that and but you're still going to
be paying our 70 dollar games you're
going to be paying attention
they're going to do that for a while i
guess i got to head out okay all right
all right we're traveling
always a pleasure brother always a
player for real same yeah we have a good
one guys
so yeah and it's kind of strange
that when you do look at it that sony is
also one of the movie studios that were
uh
wholeheartedly saying that they weren't
releasing their games on the streaming
service they were i mean in movies in a
stream of service they were releasing
their movies in the movie theater so i
think that whole thought process
permeates sony itself as the company
and don't look for day and day if the
movie section wasn't willing to do that
as far as releasing in a pandemic they
were willing to hold their movies until
the pandemic left so you can go to the
movie theater to see spider-man and
stuff like that so
um and morbius and and all other movies
trust and believe they're going to hold
on to their last breath to give you day
and date oh yeah yeah
that would be the last thing yeah i
believe that i i look at it the same way
i think like um
initially you'll get pc day long before
you get that service date yeah initially
i for remember when i announced it i was
on the one because i'm like i'm never a
fan of
we're to give you 600
gains all right what
like like i'm never into just broad
number statement because to me that
doesn't mean anything until i know
what's in it so now that we get more in
it i will say like from the triple a
standpoint and the third party
standpoint you know they're giving
people like alex said who made like for
me i've played the majorities games but
i could see how someone brand new to the
service could be like yo i'm gonna get
red dead i'm gonna get god of war now
where it does value for me is where it's
like look they're joints that let's be
honest what 70 dollars i'm not jumping
in the gran turismo like that right for
70 i'm not a demon souls guy i'm not
jump they're not going to get that from
me but now you're telling me a year
later right or a year and a half or
whatever the cadence is that that will
be it there so that was like oh i was
just gonna wait on anything i'm lukewarm
and i'll just jump in there now
obviously the big boys i'm gonna get but
um yeah i thought it was cool i thought
that list the the initial list was cool
from that that tier the um i'm with
solve though like they the thing that
pisses me off is that they do it a
little gay fast stuff and they're doing
a little nintendo stuff and nintendo got
this thing where we know damn well
nintendo you got this plethora of
history all these great games
you know supposed to be in here and i'm
a playstation one fanboy i am that veda
and psp fanboy like where they at you
know so when i come listen they like
yeah
siphon filter and i'm like i
what else you know i said like okay like
you do one psp game you got the the um
the the superstar dust or whatever and
it's like come on and then the thing for
me where i'm kind of a king on this part
is like
the ps down part still feel like it's
forced in the vector like the ps3
section is literally ps now it's like
you're going to stream these joints and
that's it and just i'm hoping like what
grub said is like please give that
download option right give that that
logo so we're not forced to stream that
aspect but look dude you know obviously
the number one question is it compared
to gay past i i don't think so but i
think you know the day and date aspect
of game pass the fact that you know you
have you can stream the games on other
devices and the fact that there's an
ultimate tier that gives you the the
whole pc aspect to it as well it's still
a more appealing package overall but i'm
not gonna sit there and say like this is
the worst the question i got because i
was yeah i forgot to ask greg before he
left was um me and maddie had this
little debate serious debate but like we
seen that ubisoft classic
is in this
and
i think it was surprising because
all the talk we always heard ubisoft
plus associated kind of with xbox right
that's going to eventually happen
ubisoft plus ubisoft plus now this is
not plus this is classic and granted
some of them games is like you know
splinter cell one and division one and
you know what i'm saying stuff like that
but i'm curious what y'all think and i
don't mean i mean you've had this
conversation on the phone but i'm
curious for solve or so solving king
like do you think because
playstation has this deal with classic
that this will prevent xbox from getting
plus that was allegedly rumored like
because that me and maddie going out
he's like yo i think sony dropped the
bag off and you know i don't know if
that deal gonna go down now you know
what i'm saying so sorry start with you
with that kick as far as ubisoft classic
and blasted so question i could have
sworn there was a ubisoft related thing
already in game pass yeah it's come in
the
it's going to comment box but it's not
part of this he's not part of it
it's part of their service their
playstation service right right you know
what do you mean it's part of their
playstations
you buy that 15 or 18 dollars i don't
know yeah whatever the highest i think
you get the classic naturally it comes
into this so on xbox it would be
a totally separate thing purchased
that's what the assumption is with the
assumption
um yeah i mean it's interesting again i
mean these th these guys are constantly
playing chess with each other trying to
block each other's moves so if the
assumption was that at some point
microsoft was going to try to make a
bigger play at ubisoft
um then yeah then then why not try to
try to block them in any which way that
you can again at the end of the day i
don't know how big that bag would be and
what that means but the just the fact
that at this point what we're looking at
is a kind of a deeper integration into
playstation that there is
there's going to be with xbox yeah you
just
you just never know you you got to think
about where ubisoft sees themselves in
the market they've had you know a number
of sort of free-to-play games that have
not hit the way they wanted to to the
point we'd have to close them you know
very quickly um the stuff they have on
the on on the horizon is is sort of like
more of the division uh sort of
free-to-play stuff yeah
uh so
in in a world where i think
playstation with this with this ps plus
sort of thing is at
some point gonna try to shore up
that uh that service with free-to-play
games with games that people could just
gravitate to and not necessarily pay
beyond you know what they would pay for
the service
and and if we and if we go with the
assumption that
even their multiplayer games that are
being developed whatever their 10
multiplayer centric games or whatever or
or
uh
service services
yeah if we're assuming that they're
gonna try to charge up front for those
games and not put them into the service
day one then it would make sense to sort
of start making these third-party deals
that in the same way that microsoft
would have back for blood or something
like that has done to sort of shore that
up so yeah it's interesting we'll see
i'm going to see what kind of this
begins to bring obviously we're looking
at older games to start with but if some
of those games do still have their
servers open
and you know and and they see sort of a
bump in the multiplayer uh aspect of
those games through that service yeah i
could definitely see that happening on
the xbox side we'll see again because
like you said if the bag has been
dropped off then conversations are only
going to get to a certain point and then
they're going to be locked up so i i
honestly don't know i think you know
when you look at
the ea stuff there on both like all of
these all of these third-party
publishers that tried their hand at
doing this themselves on the beginning
yeah realized that it wasn't the deal
are just probably trying to get their
service onto every single damn platform
they can
um so they're gonna get bet in bed with
everybody is is an assumption that's
fair to make whether you know like you
said bags are dropped off then maybe
they they're in bed with one as as
opposed to the other we'll see
so to be determined tbd tbd tbd but i do
think i do think the smart thing would
be to try to get on every platform yeah
yeah
um classic is on
you know this giant like do you think on
our playstation uh plus do you think
that that stops anything from ubisoft
plus happening with xbox do you think
it's separate where you at
well um playstation has a little curated
thing
called classics it's it's uh here we go
it's uh um me too
[Laughter]
called you big backhanded compliment
like like they they talking to great
adventures this this is dhoni park
[Laughter]
say it first you we got you be soft
classy
this is what we have inside
you got ubisoft plus launching an xbox
later
real thing the full suite like
the full seat you see you know they got
the all-inclusive you got the uh you got
yeah you got yeah
you can have the shrimps but you can't
have it
you ought to shrimp some broccoli you
just got shrimp
you don't get the broccoli
your situation don't call for that oh
yo
listen uh these dudes just amped about
it good be amped about it clap your
hands smack your feet together this
ain't blocking what somebody else is
doing well what i found out is the
family that um
is that owns the majority stake inside
ubisoft said they don't want to be sold
to anybody right and they will continue
to keep the matar majority stake in the
said company so that can never happen
now i thought they was bs'ing when it
came to that i'm like money to all bs
walk
and bust you upside your head with the
bag you're gonna fall over but now i see
that these dudes is over here giving
these dudes
small bite-sized portions of their
situation and they get in the bag
because think about it this way
without that ubisoft they join look
anemic
right so you say yes they got you
somebody got you
okay so the fact that he said okay yo
we're going we gon we're gonna give them
a little curated joint and they're gonna
be happy with this
i never seen so many dudes smacking
their feet together in their hands
together talking about oh my god king
it's crazy they got ubisoft you got
classics
they're letting you know it's not
ubisoft plus
you got the little car
you know how you went in there you
thought you look at the big version of
the escalator the retro trait the little
small the compact suv that's what we do
you get the clown car you got the clown
pack inside and all y'all can pack out
later
don't don't stop it stop it
just be happy because without this think
about it this way without this you
really ain't got nothing in that
situation
all right so y'all's like oh we got val
holla
they got red dead they got red
i've never seen dudes capped so hard for
valhalla my whole life and y'all it's
beautiful to see but it's not gonna stop
money don't stop it's not gonna stop
they got a bag from y'all they're gonna
get a bag from them they're gonna get it
back from whoever else decides they want
some curated stuff on a joint all right
microsoft was gonna get the full joint
and when y'all look over and be like wow
what's your plate look like
see the difference is but let me say
this yes the difference is when the
ubisoft plus is launched on the
microsoft platform
it's going to be like how ea plus was in
the beginning
separate fee
you understand so you're going to have
the whole ubisoft joint
you got to have the cash
get in that all right and then later on
they'll probably do some some some joint
that that it can get inside the uh the
game pass thing
it doesn't fit the game pass model but a
curated joint fits inside the
playstation joint and they did pay out
the nose for it because they look a
little anemic
but to bring it in
it it's it's a bonus it's a huge bonus
i'm not saying that it's not they're
going to keep sniping
the feds are not happy with you but i'm
just telling dudes you know stop the cap
you know y'all out here with it ain't
like y'all got something really special
no boom pow you just got boom bap
attic final thoughts or that ubisoft
classic give yourself a plastic
i feel like um
i feel like sony backed up the truck and
they they're they're stopping
uh that service from going and getting
past ultimate xbox one you bet your
knees on it i heard oh i heard i heard
name oh
sure
all right cool
so okay
june 13th i want to holla at you again
okay so what's the parameters is so
what's the best june 13th
ubisoft plus or play or whatever is in
any form or fashion on xbox your knees
is the king no it's it's got to be in
game pass no no no no no
literally the whole point of my class i
was blocking it how is it blocking me
if it's over there if it's in the
ecosystem how is it how is it a block if
so you need to tell me i literally was
talking about being in the ultimate
you're trying to do needs and then when
i when i agree to it you say oh it can't
be an ultimate well i literally said
ultimate
well
[Music]
as long as it comes over that's what you
say because that's right long as it's
inside this situation if you're in the
environment if you're in the club you're
in the club right so you're saying it
don't matter that they got to be a game
player yeah i told you it's never coming
it's not coming in game pass it's coming
to the microsoft ecosystem and it's
going to be the full they already
announced it
[Laughter]
i think they're going to put the uvs off
plus or maybe
i'll pay out the nose and and you're
going to either have that extra service
on your joint but you're going to have
the full joint i think you're going to
have a sprinkle
because ubisoft's been pretty
help uh pretty supportive over game pads
haven't they in the past
i mean just isn't isn't origins coming
um this week with uh it's finally coming
this week with uh with 60 fps i feel
like major games they don't be really
throwing thank
don't i feel like valhalla they had you
know what i know i know [ __ ] on there
they put rainbow rainbow six yeah
rainbow six is the big one but like i
feel like when i look at a game like
division two i'm like you'd be soft
games just went to game pass put it in
the the champion
yeah i i feel like a lot some of these
big joints they don't really i think
staples on there at one time
yeah was the crew on there i don't know
i believe the crew is deep was i mean
yeah we've never seen a far cry gang
yeah that's what i'm talking about the
big boy or for honor yeah you know the
big boys though
has been on there yeah has been on there
i'm talking about like the only big boy
that i consider again this is my opinion
i feel siege was a big deal and they got
them going but i'm looking for like the
valhallas and stuff day one i'm looking
for like the far cries the division twos
and you know what i'm saying even the
ghost recons i don't was the ghost
straight guys in there
i don't even know like i just feel like
some of the big ones the ones they
really champion i don't know i feel like
those don't come if they do it'd be like
really late but anyway it is what it is
i think
when it comes to the ubisoft thing i
just personally feel like because that's
the rumor we heard we heard that right
uh it's similar to ea play it's going to
be uh that service is going to be merged
with ea uh with a game pass ultimate
and i've been hearing that since like
damn near the end of 2020. we've been
hearing that it's been a minute and i
feel like this might be the reason we
because like if you look at a lot of um
a lot of predictions to last e3 people
said that oh you know play uh ubisoft
plus has come into uh the service and i
think maybe at some point in time you
know sony back that truck up like we
want your stuff in our service so
i i just i i think you're going to see
the service itself but you're not going
to get it like tagged on the ultimate
you're going to have to pay for it well
y'all both agree at the same point
you're both saying the same thing anyway
moving on that's all i got so if you
want to get these super chat before we
get to the last time
hold on let me make sure nothing else
i think i got everything i think while
you do that i think yeah i think i got
we got oh yeah yeah yeah we got um shout
out he didn't say anonymous somebody
bought
the long sleeve throw him in the bushes
i haven't seen them in the bushes in a
minute saluted
shout out shout out to you getting that
cause i didn't get a chance to talk to
uh
yeah that guy for whatever reason hasn't
moved like i don't know
well you know what
the the design on it needs to be we need
to revamp we need to rebuild
we need to fix that bill we need to go
over there to be honest with you a lot
of our yeah we're going to do a we're
going to do a merge revamp y'all we're
going to do a merger but salute to you
for anonymous
next time when you're on the checkout
leave a comment so we could give y'all
you know what i'm saying shout out
official it was me
every time you don't leave a comment i'm
going to claim your stuff
i bought it it's still being shipped to
your addict with that kit you're
wretching that anyway
i'm taking the credit for the buy i
didn't buy it
yeah okay so we got uh a couple that i
missed so shout out to hargeet for oh
she's shouting out because i didn't
realize that
she needed a homie so we got hearty
chinese five dollars salute to the lords
for all of those not able to continue
paying for game pass here's a
three-month slow ball
so the the the the
the uh super chat was in the chat so i'm
assuming somebody got yeah somebody
probably grabbed it
so shout out to hargy thank you so much
for uh for you know providing for the
children yes yes helping out the
unfortunately yes
there we have christopher jetzer five
dollar super chat weird west is engaged
past i would chris he says christopher
heart i would love
[Laughter]
weird west is in game pass i would love
for evil west to come to game pass do we
know if uh ew is coming i don't that's
what i meant because i meant evil west i
know weird west was in there but i don't
know
if you i saw it i was talking about
weird west not evil west
i lost you
i don't know
oh okay damn
no todd got up
this guy put his head down it was
silence for me no no i don't know if
it's on there and i don't know if it's
coming drawn tj ten dollars if we chat
dude i hate these people capping saying
game pass has no value now and there are
no game no new games really you have
forza sniper elite five which i love i
can't wait to shoot some nazis into the
crotch and mlb the show take your butt
over to playstation and pay 80
and we got mikey mighty five five
dollars if we chat since it would be
difficult for xbox to buy a japanese
studio could phil sent shinji mikami a
bag to expand tango gameworks i mean
yeah you could always expand tango
that's for sure
then we have jazz gordon ten proud super
chat jeff is a cheater battle shrimp
forever and yeah i guess
their battles online then we have donald
taku five dollars super chat i feel like
the series x and s will eventually
overtake the 360 when xcloud takes off
and they get a console to seamlessly
connect at home also okay so he's saying
that the console in conjunction with
playing things in the cloud on their
phones
will work we'll see and we got jazz
again five pound super chat jeff told me
in dm that persona is definitely coming
to exit
then we got hollywood rules five dollars
a chat
jumped onto here king jumped onto here
the king wants the 3ds reparations love
iop sundays have a great show my
brothers are you guys still doing a
doctor strange review hashtag reggie
shebang
i think me and addict need to do that
because i don't know about these other
two guys yeah you got over 600 people in
the chat let's get those likes up share
that out please
then we got mr irishman 10 pounds super
chat i seen square trademarks final
fantasy vii integrated again could this
mean that the mythical xbox port is
coming could xbox lean on third party to
get more ports that previously skipped
the console to fill this year yeah we'll
come with a switch
probably
then we got lord meyerhoff shout out to
you sir member for nine months i agree
with saab regardless of how the xbox is
doing in japan if there are no if there
is no demand no way the console would be
sold like this despite ps5 problems
exactly there is demand people like it
then we got her geek cheney dollar super
chat yakuza zero one and two did leave
game pass unfortunately okay so those
did leave has to be fairly recently yeah
um
then we have mr irishman member for 11
months
xbox should money hat the next tales of
game and near games both of those series
with the microsoft aaa budget on game
pass day one would make waves i would
just make waves to be on their day one
period that would be something
then we got drogba five dollar
much love lords japan is a design
forward market in terms of form factor
the series s won this round that is for
sure i agree with that
little man outside little man salute
and we got necromancer zale 10 super
chat i like the xbox supporting more
japanese studios but i don't want them
taking their eyes off eastern european
studios i feel that they've been the
most innovative studios in video games
right now
yeah i don't think they've yeah i think
their eye is on the prize there as well
yeah
uh the brightest sun with the five
pounds super chat microsoft would do a
big splash in japan by acquiring a
publisher and i bet on and i bet on
capcom as only capcom does not have
hotels pachinko's anime or manga
business
actually
i actually feel like we'll get them i
actually feel like they have a better
chance of buying a company that is
focusing on other stuff because they're
not valuing the gaming portion of their
company so i feel like sega is a good uh
candidate because like sammy doesn't
seem like they care but the thing is
sega sold out a lot of their stuff too
as well like they were clean they got
they got attractive so we'll see
no place
[Music]
i will say this i will say that sonic
doing well might have uh a lot to say
and where they go in the future oh man
they ain't going no place
they're pockets
come outside
oh my god yo yo this is the crazy thing
if yo it is gonna hit because that's
sonic movies but buck bananas
so the thing is these dudes is out here
the better they do the more think about
it this way the more money you have in
your pocket can anybody tell you
anything
[Laughter]
i really can't hear you bro
don't let phil come out there with the
sacred shirt um
the wildest thing about this um what i
don't like is and
really about the ubisoft thing that you
was talking about earlier this i really
can't stand this on that on that third
party preview
indie developer
showcase crap that we got mad crap for
yeah valhalla was front and center right
how the hell it make it across the
street
when you rolled out the red carpet oh
you don't like them talking to them
dudes listen y'all
because if that game don't make it to
your platform before and you spend the
money to show it
you was out there twirling around
third party joint and she was front and
center remember i was like odin
all that other stupid stuff that i was
saying
i know it's curating that's why i told
you you was over there he was attic he
was big captain last
[Laughter]
ah
way
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's true i forgot about that they had
the marketing rights for valhalla they
put it in there that was like a front
and center series x yeah
they drove her to the prom and
everything
and she was dancing with the next she
did yeah she outside she's definitely
outside you got her
yes you're over there with classic
rollies and i don't know what's going on
over there highly disgusting highly
disrespected
that right there is
member for 24 months thank you brother
afternoon lords good to see the homie
grub in the realm in regards to this
topic sony stopped caring for japan when
the main button went from old to x that
was a big deal though that was
underrated that was crazy
shout out to jim jim's laid the lord out
he's a european thing bro they sony
stopped caring about japan when he
dissolved the studio
yeah yeah
you
make games that get served in the box
it was a new day he came through i like
your style make those games and shipping
about astro
[Laughter]
happy lord's day lads jeff keep rocking
it cox see you soon oh pull up and why
brother when you pull up you already
know we're gonna do it big big time
you'll be so having a building my man
carpet lords of gaming.net in the
building and the um oh man why am i
forgetting every everything xbox
everything xbox one of the most highly
growing uh facebook uh groups and
communities on in in in the rounds to
salute to my man
we had them all remember he came through
one time i'm gonna say it pulled up so
it's a little tip yo adam you gotta get
out of that out that chair we gotta
bring wood chair back at it but he
do this when you see addict do this you
know that [ __ ] is right you're right his
head all crazy
that [ __ ] get a napkin it's
[Applause]
then we got our flame two dollar super
chat i i
i think they didn't break the star fruit
news day i think he's talking about uh
japan
they're selling in japan because they
haven't built nobody
yet okay news travel slow mm-hmm there
we
go we got
necromancer sale two dollar super chat
borrower would fit in nicely with
bethesda
let's see
oh yeah shout out the big cloud of homie
new lords
[Laughter]
i'm late but i made it oh that's the
whole thing
no doubt absolutely
all that
then we got uh donald taco five dollars
they just announced the yakuza crossover
in rainbow six siege
these live service game crossovers are
getting out of control that's crazy yeah
i looked it up that's true i don't know
what the heck that is but that's that's
that's kind of awesome
then we got double ray 2 super chat on
416 ubisoft announced plus is coming to
ps to playstation later so they are
bringing the plus version of that
we gotta pay for that
then we got the curator
like that's some value bill yeah
no broccoli
we got lord metroid two dollars with a
chat check an indie game called
may for nado okay it looks great okay
i'll look that up
then we have okay we jumped a little bit
almost recycled
back
we got echelon seven the darkness
remember for 17 months
shout out to the hilarious lords from
fordham heights peace to the room
salute to the lords this my sunday
school fellas uh war anderson
silva the goat i gotta give it to him
that boy was something different him and
floyd making it look easy yes a little
bit low no doubt
what's he got then we got donald taco
ten dollar super chat i don't know if
y'all seen that the new atomic heart
trailer but yeah what the newest part
but it looks so fire i'm still hoping it
makes it this year but if not gamepad's
gonna be even more brazy in 2023 yeah i
was that's actually it was going to be
one of my predictions like we see atomic
heart big time this year
i better not find its way into a curated
edition
but then
the dubs is all the way around yeah
we all caught up all right let's get
this last one up and get up out of here
it's attic too comfortable um yeah we
got to get
is king's topic man bungie very
outspoken recently um some comments
about they won't be muzzled over by sony
over abortion rights comments shout out
to metro dot co so um yeah so it looks
like um while and some act was forced to
keep quiet about the abortion rights
debate in the u.s bungie pledges not to
be silenced by its new owner the
majority of the games industry has kept
quiet over the league supreme court
draft that says it will over overturn
roe v wade bungie was the first studio
to publicly decry it short after the
leak they made they said his decision is
a blow to freedom in america it's so
definitely a lengthy stamp i'm not gonna
read the whole statement but they were
definitely against that um and then they
said this is not sony's take on the
issue playstation boss jim ryan recently
sent out a letter to employees asking
them to respect differences of opinion
among everyone regarding the issue now i
said with bungie set to become a first
party studio there are concerns that its
new owner will attempt to silence bungie
and prevent it from taking public
stances like this in the future so shout
out to skill up i think he put a tweet
out and was saying that as a result of
that it would you know kind of suck if
bungie because they've been known to be
outspoken you know um would be
silence however bungie itself promised
that that will not happen with our
senior community manager dylan gaffner
shout out to dmg on twitter he said
there will never be a muzzle big enough
to stop us from standing up for what's
right ceo pete parks and then backed up
dylan's comment and said insinuating
that if sony ever attempts to silence
bungie on this or any similar political
matters bungie will adamantly defy so i
think i now know why i suck king joe's
topic so king the floor is yours you
know what do you want to say about this
stuff because we don't do the political
stuff but first of all we're not going
to talk about the seriousness of rule
versus way right correct
my jokes only stems
from a whole different perspective yes
where are you going and this and this is
just jokes
you ever been outside somebody and
you're like yo what you going outside
with that why are you wearing that
you're not gonna tell me what to do
i know you did not listen now
be married that don't mean you own me oh
no only i get to do and choose
what i'm outside so remember in the
beginning of the contract right
he was like yeah we'll sign with you but
we gotta be for everybody
so so
now you got a first party studio with
they gotta say with a caveat the
thoughts and opinions of bungie does not
reflect
the owner proprietor of beset bungie
in fear of upsetting bungie and bungie
taking a ball and going home because we
know what bungie do when they don't
as a like yo i'm just saying
they ain't even get the first game out
we're seeing a little bit of back talk
what's up man the check yo the checks
ain't even clear the ink ain't even dry
and they like who you talking to like
yo
oh no he did not know
he must not know who you talking to
you got me messed up for somebody else
boy oh no you better read the fine print
in the fine print i do what i want how
do i choose why i choose when i do
your best what they said budgie
all right so
and all seriousness right we're not
going to look at the seriousness of that
whole thing and the whole
we are here for the jokes we play video
games we're not in the political arena
this is not it i saw a levity in
something that was serious and we have
to bring a little bit of levity
so that's all i'm talking about
and i want y'all to address it on that
level okay okay we're not on the other
level okay addict so is bungie acting up
in these streets and will she have to
bend the knee because i mean sony got
that you know cut the check
it just depends on how well those
lawyers did when they drafted that uh
that
that contract
is known to be
super ill they got out of activision
they got out of microsoft this is like a
different thing
this is a little bit different than the
activision thing
um because we don't
we i still feel like you know we have to
see a little bit in terms of like how
they they interact with the company
after it's made but this this proves
like you know like
act bungie could be told what to do in
any way shape or form
uh you know it
i'm curious
if it's like you know sony and
bungie are like the honeymoon phase and
bungie uh sony don't know if they want
to really come out there and say stuff
like right now but you know like it's
easy to say
that you are
that you could speak out and sony can't
do nothing when you're on the right side
of the other argument you know what i'm
saying like
i'm curious if they was on the wrong
side of the argument would they be so
would sony really let them come out
there and say stuff it doesn't matter
you know we're not going to know that
until you know they say something that's
very you know against the against the
wind you know what i'm saying like we
got to see that like obviously it's okay
to say something like this because
for the most part everyone's on the same
level right you know that's not right so
we got to see hold on i got i got to
come for christopher he told me i never
i never bothered him but i got to cover
because he said sony most likely did not
want to get involved not really silent
stuff come on now here's the caviar
christmas because
it is a little bit of silences because
of the um obviously they're going to
talk about the issue like king said yeah
but let's talk about this because of the
issue
right
after a controversial email by
playstation boss jim ryan leaked a
report surfaced that developer insomniac
games sent a 60-page document to sony
the para company demanding that it does
better by its employees so they
insomniac did not like jim ryan but get
this
sony are reportedly
donating to a reproductive rights
organization but under one condition
playstation studios aren't allowed to
release any official statements no more
on the matter so there is a it's like
all right
movement yeah bungie started a movie
just don't go to the public with you
with what you feel this really could
like this could be a domino effect where
you know
a lot of here's the thing like
regardless you can't do nothing about
the studios the students already bought
bungie's a little bit different because
they you know they got the clauses they
love their clauses but when it comes to
the other studios that's how you start
losing
talent
is when you don't let people speak about
stuff they feel strongly about
especially all the women talent that
work for their companies
that that's when it gets slippery
because then at that point if you're in
the you got that aspect where you're not
letting people talk then you got another
aspect with like you're not delivering
enough like bungie does why can't they
talk but i can't
and then
person here
got all his power
i've been here for 25 years i don't know
why he got seniority
oh like you doing the hood ratchet chick
boys i always get christmas off why the
hell now i gotta work christmas and they
get christmas off
please tell me sony yeah like i said
that uh like i said dylan's comments
were very strong he said i admit i'm
just a community managing the grand
scheme but i'm confident in the
following we are and will continue to be
bungee there will never be a muzzle big
enough to stop us from standing up well
he said a muzzle big enough
your money's ain't cool over here like
that no money don't buy nothing and then
pete
pete parson the ceo of bungie when
somebody say yo we we certain you know
we'll pete because pete's really the
decision maker but when she goes to
community management pete was like
fairly saying that uh pete will stand by
dylan on this comment which is community
manager and pete parsons replied he said
yeah i did
so he co-signed
i'm down with the messages
i'm down with the two it's just at the
end of the day when stuff hits the fan
are they willing to lose that money sony
gonna funnel through that company
i don't know shout out because it's one
thing to say something
they got their checks but they want
chess in the future they just want that
addict to your point shout out to hug
i'm gonna skip that solve shout out to
heartless
the games too shout out to hawaii with
the files which he says sony can't
really tell bungie to do anything as the
acquisition is not complete still has to
pass regulatory approval so the ring
ain't on on just yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
i hope
you don't be crazy because bungie's
really
really big on freedom of speech they're
really big on speaking on uh matters
that are important yeah they are what's
crazy is like this thing with the emails
the thing with uh you know uh with um
insomniac games once a bungie pulls out
of the team
but if we go we go play devil advocate
saudi jim reinstatements get attacked
but jim ryan just say hey i guess like
don't pick a side let let it just keep
it down put it down
don't tell me
telling people not to pick a side is
picking a side at that point so exactly
being silenced is you know but we're not
going to talk about that but
the funny part about all of this
it ain't even official
they already got other people at
democracy out there
i
i hope that it's exactly how bungie says
that sony's not going to like intervene
with what systems their games release on
sony's not going to come in and tell
them oh you know we we don't want you i
hope bungie's serious and they they're
and they know exactly that they can't be
told to do certain things but i don't
know part of me just feels like look
like when you spend that kind of money
you're gonna do it part of me does kind
of feel like it's gonna be like sony
gonna pop in there
but here's the thing i feel you but
right now we get to the ceremony yet so
if that's the time to act up it's now to
see where you act with it right see
but see and then it's just like what we
said we ain't we the date we ain't even
signed we got to pay we never got a
so how do we know that if that paperwork
signed sony on that
yo you're gonna yo you gotta stop it now
don't make me come down there and kick
that dude off to social media i'm just
saying budgie got some of the best
lawyers i have ever seen they got tina
turner i don't even know how they
negotiated this deal that those games
are not exclusive to the playstation
it's not that they don't have good
lawyers it's that i'm concerned that the
people of bungie themselves are
corruptable where it's like when you see
the steady money coming through
you see this
but i mean money changes things
it's one thing to get that number
it's one thing to get that money it's
another thing to keep that money and
when you want to fund this matter fund
this destiny that shit's expensive but
here's the thing i don't know bungie's
gonna willingly be like you know
at that point it's like if you put a
line in that in the sand
are you willing to cross that line for
just anything i don't know well i mean
the fact that you outside they outside
talking the way they talk and shows me
that that's where their position is at
and they understand the repercussions
because this is just to me to say before
it's actually done but they've done this
when they were already under the control
of activision and they said yeah we
don't care what you talk about you know
i'm saying we believe in our product we
willing to stand on any square they've
shown but they didn't they didn't sell
themselves to activision it was a
partnership yeah but they was able to
get out of a deal that nobody thought
they could get out of yeah we thought
they was locked up i thought they would
have i just i gotta see it i gotta see
what happens and how they move after the
deals i'm with you guys i feel like
bungie have been very vocal and bungie
will most likely continue to be bungie
but i wouldn't be surprised if when that
money starts hitting and they can fund
the games that they want to fund if that
management starts thinking differently
yeah we got to see i think honestly
if they was to say you know what we
don't like that
we don't like your house we don't like
what's going on over there
and you know what certain portions in
this contract is ours this money's out
we good you paid ahead of time you
and be like hey boo boo
it's like i said i got
i got to see how bungie interacts with
the type of money sony has look we
always clown saying sony is this sony
broke that but so they got money money
and i'm curious all in the club they
broke
i just i'm personally curious to see
exactly how sony interacts
with them and how once that funding
starts getting funneled through there
now they got to worry about you know are
they going to make this quarter they're
going to make that quarter i'm curious
how much pushback bungie will
realistically give to the people giving
them the chance the sony fans of the
rover saying that we are wishing for
this deal to go back oh no no no just
the same way that you're wishing for
activision not to happen
you don't hear
me saying the word see activision is
desperately looking for the ring to be
put on and they're quiet as a church
all people's is over there like listen
here
you're not gonna tell me what to do it's
tuesday and i go out for tacos
i thought that was the hand
i got a king i thought it was a hand
ejector listen here
this is hilarious so we did not get your
thoughts on this
we outside give us your thought songs
[Music]
bungie is
[Applause]
and i see a third divorce oh you see the
divorce i see it happening right i see
it happening they're gonna get past this
this little bump you're gonna go
backwards
if it even happens like at this point
like it you know what's going to happen
it's good they're going to come in
previously
and then this is going to happen again
it's going to keep happening again
you're going to keep trying to muzzle
you're going to and then where does that
lead you back home with it back right
back
straight up this ain't gonna work like
it's not it's just not gonna work like
bungie is of the source today they made
it clear they're not gonna tell us what
to do and at some point
at some point
sony has to draw the line and say this
is our message yeah
yeah this is it that's an addiction
under our umbrella yep this is our
message
i paid for all this you can't just go
all willy nilly be like i gotta do what
i'm gonna do
like yo i'm gonna use this as an example
let's go um
remember when um
remember when ign
when they they went and they they they
they took a stance on uh africa i
believe it was the i forgot exactly what
it was
israel yeah exactly they took a stance
on on on on a genocide subject or
whatever they took a stance and the
problem was that they thought they had
the right or maybe they knew when they
just tried to push the envelope
they thought they had the right to
take what they felt maybe as as as a
group as an editorial group or whatever
they thought they had the right to
dictate
what the owners at ign
believe or choose to believe or choose
to put out on their on their website
that they own that you work for
at the end of the day you know what
happened there was a whole big to do
about that there was nothing
at the end of the day what happened to
that quiet oh nothing because
you can't do it it's not your company
you can't you cannot at the end of the
day just say what you feel like saying
under this umbrella which is why they
will they but the thing is bungie will
do that and eventually it's going to be
too much
what's going to happen i'm just going to
tell you right now the void's going to
happen again bungie's going to realize
that they aren't they're they only
function by themselves
welcome to happy burger week
they don't they don't have a wedding
date yet they're in the recording and
engagement they're gonna they're gonna
look at all the positives of this of
this union and they're going to convince
themselves that this is for the greater
good it's going to happen we're going to
want to work this out
and when when you convince yourself
you're going to work something out that
you know is a problem at its core
all you're doing is prolonging the
inevitable that's all you're doing all
right but why can't all right let's
because the chat is attacking us so let
let's let me flip this so why can't it
be
you like you are you know how you
marriage all right you write for me i'm
right for you you don't say addict you
know how it is
then you had that first big fight like
what you mean you know what i'm saying
you won't be leaving the toilet seat up
you'll be acting up you're doing all
type of craziness right and it's that
first and sometimes it take that first
fight to be like okay you know what we
can't cross the line here with that but
everything else is good and then we
could move forward what if this is that
that teaching moment and it gets them
closer to the relationship when you have
two entities that both believe
themselves to be alphas
it ain't happening
it ain't happening because bungie out
here bungie out here somehow
finagling these deals that no other
company of their size boss level we keep
the game they multi-player right so they
you know they're not lacking in
self-confidence
[Applause]
this is they're going to continue to
believe that this is okay
until it ain't until just like
so they're just the open relationship
company that's just why i believe
solving's on to something and it may not
work
it's because they starting to infect the
other people that was in line
they understand like like when you when
you start to infect the other people
that was like yeah you know i'm down
with that what you said
you got did he did what
oh me too
i don't know first place once it start
happening
and then you start changing the mindset
we have never heard this is the best
part about this right
usually sony is buttoned up quiet we
don't hear nothing over there right now
we just heard about a email from the
lead news
who started the rumor like
i got an email from you know who
yo cassandra said soft just called
bungie jaden
[Laughter]
[Music]
abound oh
there okay finish your point
[Music]
i personally feel like what we're
probably going to see
is either bungie is going to leave early
or
like maybe within a year year and a half
or yeah they're gonna stay long enough
to where it's just how it is oh you know
sony they might not let me speak on
issues but they make sure i'm good i got
a roof over my head i i got plenty of
money to eat like so people say people
take that shut up buddy i don't yeah i i
i you know people do it all the time i
wouldn't be surprised like look at the
other day we might talk about all this
you know
all this extra stuff that bungie does do
behind closed doors but at the end of
the day none of that keeps the light on
and you could they wouldn't have sold a
sony they weren't somewhat
financially
and not able to move the way they wanted
to and when you can formally move the
way you want to
sooner or later you're going to you
you're going to get in line like
all right let's say this right let's say
you saying you know i'm i'm single
unless the right situation come around
right and you know you you're
financially stable you're good you don't
need anything i'm single unless the
right situation come around and then
some some girl comes up and she got
everything together she got all that
stuff and then she tell you and you can
do whatever you want to do mm-hmm this
excuse you
it's an open relationship but you're
going to pay for this that in the third
and everything good yeah you can
continue doing everything that you want
to do i'm just going to give you some
money
just going to give you some money who
the hell going to say no um
i'm going to say yes please let me give
you that we have to see
what this actually entails to
all we know is that bungie has the
opposite the the the the set the last
say in a lot of the issues but like i
said when you start funneling that money
back and forth people at bungie can
easily be like we need that now like
they like it doesn't take much to
uh to
to put your own people in place for all
we know
in the next couple years people are sony
start replacing the people at bungie
well we don't know what's gonna highly
disagree i highly disagree because it
lit we had hole on and hulk talked about
this deal he said structurally it is set
up where they can't replace stakeholders
they everything has to be intact like
they've even got to replace the
stakeholders
to create
they have literally said
if the ceo is coming out now
and saying that
to me you already understand the risks
involved i'm not saying that they can't
get in line and eventually they have
some type of argument and i'm not saying
it's definitely going to fall apart all
i'm saying is that
they are maneuvering and structuring
deals with partnerships in ways that are
unheard of for a game company in my
opinion so it is going to be interested
in the chart i don't know how this is
going to play out my gut right now says
it is too
advantageous for both of them to make
this work sony needs this too
sony needs live service game bungie has
leverage you know what i'm saying they
realize what's going on so i do think
if now if now's the time to fight you
fight now i do and you see where it's at
you're good yeah i do feel like sony has
more leverage than bungie because bungie
could have did it to anyone why sonya
yeah but bungie took money from tinsel
like bungie had because it makes money
because yeah because it's a perfect
marriage they got bungie once bungie
feels the destiny ip can go everywhere
and these guys have the movie interest
they're seeing the spider-man stuff
they're seeing the lights the glitz and
diamonds and then one is seeing the
other side like yo we don't really have
multiplayer and live service games we
don't really know how to do that as well
from a first party stan could you help
train like this deal is different it's
not just we're taking destiny and that's
it we're taking you and your expertise
to help us develop these type of games
we don't really know how to do that
that's a
undertaking
that's where i i do i i double stand on
that because it's like when you
when you want all these avenues you want
to be in the movies you you want to be
in all these different forms of
entertainment and you have someone that
is in these forms of entertainment can
help you do them
i that's why i still feel like sony has
the the most leverage here because they
they're the one they get way
more out of this than
bungie does but like bungie
get they get funding sony gets uh to
pretty much do they get the marketing
rights to destiny from here on out they
can do pretty much but they don't own
the ip and the ip goes everywhere which
is unheard of
which is unheard of of acquisition
they're telling them an all future game
not only do you got that i mean we're
seeing that your game is going to be
multiplied that is unheard of
i mean it's probably going to happen
with activision too well
it's just like my thing is when it comes
to this is
i got to see what happens when they the
the cell was inked
when everything's dropped that's what i
got i get that and to me them acting up
now is a clear indicator they're not
budging yeah that is a clear indicate
because you don't if you don't want to
ruffle feathers if you're scared you
like yo shut up are you trying to
protect me yeah like yo why are you
dylan will you be quiet
you know what i said but we'll see we'll
see i i understand your point though you
just want to see once the ink is dry if
this energy is the same i know where you
are because you said
nothing like this has happened before
i'm expecting a but somewhere
so like until i don't see that but
somewhere i'm assuming some alternative
motive that the public don't know and to
me the way they structure deals is
unheard of they move
different but we'll see we'll see how
this player is
so goodman it's so good yes let it chat
yo we got monitors y'all this is this is
a fun one solve is had to step away so
um i will do the poll while we get you
see addicts if you could queue up your
super chats while i don't know how long
yeah i'll do the poll
i don't even know the last one he did
yeah we got hopefully again if not i'll
have to jump in there and help but um
let's get this
logged in ilp poll with the series s
outselling the ps5 for one week in japan
do you think the series s generation of
consoles including the series x will
outpace all other generation of xbox
consoles before the choices are a series
s will easily be xbox one in japan but
not og xbox or 360.
b series s will surpass every xbox one
and xbox og but not 360.
series s1c series generation consoles
will be the eventual leader of all
previous xbox consoles before it
or d
i don't care little man is outside these
streets and nintendo switch is next
don't call it a comeback that's the king
section
[Laughter]
please rock the ilp vote it goes up go
check that out yes flame we know you
vote d every time you know um so let's
get this all right off you're back with
the uh super chats and get the ball out
of here
let me get these real quick
so funny um let me see
let me roll back a little bit yeah
and real quick um
on the gaming attic channel i'll put the
uh
uh the link in the chat i'm gonna be
doing stuff a lot different over there
i'm gonna be real with you guys uh the
news wants me to off myself
i tried to do that kind of uh
that kind of content anymore like i'll
still do it but it's just like i got to
do what's it just
i
the news has always worked out for me
because everything always interested me
but now
nothing interests me in the news anymore
so
i got i gotta i gotta move that over so
i'm gonna be probably doing a lot more
live streams over there maybe some let's
plays uh you know just gonna experiment
a little bit find out what's enjoyable
for me to do so i'll put that uh in the
chat uh you guys go over i don't know
how many of you are following me on my
actual youtube channel gaming addict uh
but definitely uh look for look look
into that in the next couple days i'll
probably post something there no that
will salute the attic in the attic show
in the direction go support so are we
ready to rock yeah we're good we're good
we're good good hold on a second uh thx
1138 five dollar super chat insomniacs
games is also on a standoff on social
media about personal rights with sony hq
yes yeah i mean
everybody's rebelling yeah
there's not trying to
yeah i agree with king but bungie has
probably started a lot of that and if
and if it wasn't there people were
thinking it and now people are saying
she was vocal they was like me
i guess king already right there sony
can't really tell bundy do anything as
the acquisition is not complete still
has to pass regulatory approval yeah
shout out to algae
then we have alex escort member for 10
months thank you sir bundy don't want to
want to be muzzled like they try to do
with marty o'donnell i think they just
settled tomorrow
yeah they didn't settle with marty that
was dope
then we got lord metro two dollars in
the chat bungie and sony on novellas
telemundo 7 p.m eastern time
[Music]
then we got double rate two dollars from
chat i appreciate how you guys handled
such a tough topic yeah just fun and
games here is all jokes 100 percent
we've always used our platform to get
away from all these
stuff that's going on about the world
absolutely
addictive was talking about like how's
this time it gonna go it says like
[Laughter]
and plus it's like you know we are
gaming podcasts like we're not political
we're like none of that absolutely yeah
and we've got haruki chinese super chat
this relationship in quotes
is going to be more tumultuous bungie
with two american companies didn't work
a japanese one good luck savvy you're
probably right this isn't going to last
may not even be bought i think i think
the purchase happens i think it goes
through they want their money cooler
head's gonna prevail she's gotta have
that first fight
for the fight that they don't yeah
she gotta act up in the restaurant one
time and then y'all have to
that public joke
y'all at the restaurant you hear i know
you ain't just say that
this is a rap after that
yo that's the argument
irreconcilable differences
oh don't let you get to who you think
you're talking to don't know about that
one gig
then look over there that's how you at
your table y'all
i can't
i can't
let's go
all right then we have uh john wolf x
five dollar super chat jim ryan gonna
find out bungie is like amber heard when
he finds that dookie on his best
yo
stop it stop it wolf dude that's some of
the worst stuff that i found out boy
yeah that was
oh man that was horrible listen listen
don't ever fight with just to never get
over just leaving them
then we got jean-marc louis two dollars
super chat microsoft this bungie's first
baby daddy always baby
then we got urban gorilla five dollars
shout out to the lords have a blessed
day you would absolutely hello you
already know then we got john wolfe
again five dollars we'll be chat jim
gonna find out oh no no that one's
jumping one second i got that one
already
yeah wait hold on it may be different
no hold on we got john wolfe again okay
i guess he put it yeah he put it twice
no no yeah he caught it yeah he kind of
put it twice you know he put a variant
on it it's the same kind of but it
definitely wrote it a different way yeah
try to tell her no yeah
when you tell somebody no you're gonna
get those reactions
then you got gaming forte five dollar
super chat somebody saw that big booty
on bunji was like that's the woman for
me rush to put a ring on before living
together that altar could be lonely
and then you gave me fourth day once
again 2010 oh i forgot and as always hey
king boo-boo
all right guys bye guys
hi guys
we got one more john mark louis two
dollars with that sony trying to turn
bungie into a housewife and it ain't
going to happen they got that man
straight so look we made it salute
everybody salute to jeff grubb pulling
down for us
you know give us that exclusive nether
realm exclusive
if that happened and they actually did
buy another round
like king you you might as well you got
to give you got to get throw to me now
phil dominar
[Music]
you don't know me yet they'll pick up
netherrealm and you just see me come in
with a mortal kombat yeah
because he would take it from him yes he
would do that i could see king showing
up and he's like i said they wouldn't
buy it so they won't buy it
that's right finish him that's all
you're gonna hear me saying
anyway lord attic where can the five
people find you what you got going on
sir
oh you can find me on twitter
iop you can also find me on youtube at
gaming attic like i said i'm going to
put the uh
link in the description there uh
appreciate every jackrabbit on it's uh
always a fun time with jeff grove
i will be i think we're going to because
i know we owe you a stream
so probably we're going to be doing that
with overcooked because that was on the
list that you guys voted for
so we're going to do that i don't know
when i'll have to talk to them probably
after the podcast
saturday
for me
yeah so we'll do that uh
eventually
and uh appreciate everyone coming
through we are going uh me and king will
probably do uh i know some of you asked
about the doctor strange
um the doctor strange coverage i'm still
interested only big king i'm in it too
he tried to get me i know i don't like
this landing but the thing i i don't
know if i'll be able to do it next
weekend oh you know
oh see just left for the record i was
slammed
he just
didn't hear the part where he said that
you could only hang out on saturday oh
yeah that's cool let's go let's go let's
go didn't you literally just say
saturday yeah no no that's cool i'm fine
with that i just wanna keep trying to
push this down like there's only two
dudes trying to work on this
[Laughter]
uh
i think i said it wrong yeah i said
attic and i see it usually first all
right right right and then we say yo
you're nervous to wait one
[Laughter]
yeah so we'll be doing that and uh i
don't know if you guys noticed uh some
of you might catch on and watch the
uh the show uh the the segment we do on
the website called uh lord's minute yes
it's pretty much just like a writer on
the website
links up with the lord and they talk
about like certain subjects we're going
to be starting to release some of those
on the
the actual uh youtube channel
we're still doing uh talking about the
logistics on it all that but definitely
look out for that we have one up on
she-hulk right now uh that uh king uh
broke yeah king and prince broke up the
uh uh you know the trailer for she-hulk
so you can definitely go check that out
it's on the channel right now
and just like i said appreciate ever
coming through we add up to like 750
almost it might have been 800 i wouldn't
pay attention to the whole bot guys
but it was a really good show man you
know we got
363 likes of 530 people in here uh you
know
[Laughter]
he will break the ceiling in that room
damn sure not doing no cartwheels around
none of these statues
and if i catch anybody down here doing
cartwheels
[Laughter]
we're gonna play we're gonna play the
old game put them in the casket
no doubt lord solve what can you find
people find what you got going on yeah
man nothing going on nothing going on
crazy oh you know how that goes you know
pending yeah yeah pending next
not this week next week so finally i'll
be i'll be able to not live in out of a
box um
and yeah shout out to grub man you know
it's it's so cool to like before like
yeah jeffrey like jeff grove coming on
was like he was good
and it's like this is where we're at now
yeah
i love that i love that man it's so cool
that you know
i love that about for where we came from
and if people are willing to take time
out they didn't go let me pull up i got
you and i love that yeah when he's when
he's packing and moving too and yeah
that's crazy so proud shout out to y'all
for being here man we got 800 like on on
the rag that is crazy
also got a shout out we got a shout out
whole lord moving out here man yeah
man i'm so proud of him right now he's
doing big things he's doing this
obviously he's got the podcast thing
going on but what he's doing right now
he's killing the game and it's cool to
see you know
just behind the scenes i i don't know if
he want this out there but i just think
it's so cool because i'll message him
and he'll be like still like you know if
you need me for lp and i'm like
i love the environment that we've built
you know what i'm saying and people
still have that love and they don't
their head didn't get different because
you know how it is with people certain
people yeah
you know yeah i'm so proud of so yo
salute whole law man that is a beautiful
thing
no doubt that's how i guess
oh i said man that's that's a i saw for
as intelligent as that man is that man
is the smartest man in the room a lot of
the time a lot of them
he's just the humble dude speaking of
moving and shaking out here i see the
legendary hip hop gamer in the building
yo yo god bless i'll be [ __ ] y'all miss
you bro yo i'm so proud of you too
brother like he you want to talk about
me
i got to call him yeah i probably call
you on monday bro i seen you i s every
time i see you as inspiration every time
he's always doing something massive the
shout out at pax was just a movie but
like made me uncomfortable yeah i was
just not using that level of spotlight
like this is insane
let me just push it to you guys i'm
walking past i don't like being i don't
like being noticed or anything like that
i go in front of hip-hop he's like oh
she's a smart addict
he's not talking he's on a microphone
yes for the whole
whole convention
[Laughter]
yo that's him and i'm just proud of him
bro he's everywhere he goes he's doing
something humongous he's with the
biggest people in the industry he's
doing things for himself salute to him
man he's an inspiration for us as well
and always we got to get him back i feel
like we haven't had a more iop and it's
been a minute yeah we got to get him
back on iop back shout out to ready for
me we got to get the king of the club
i'm at the sony show yeah
well they ain't got one next stop
stop it
you got dirty you got dirty you got
dirty you gotta do it y'all see what you
did there
lord king we're gonna fight your fuzzy
what you gotta go to sir besides being
messy you find me not bothering bungie
yo shout out to jeff grub yes um
that's it it's dope mm-hmm he's dope to
see a lot of things that's happening oh
grub in the chat he said he loved the
pop and putting free stuff on my curve
now
that's that move i know you're getting
rid of that stuff you don't need yeah
yeah come and get it because uh we are
hoarders we all uh
i got i got size small shirts that i
can't fit and i'm still holding on to
them like i'll get down to that size
yeah okay
but
respect respect to everybody that pulled
up it means a lot you really really do
um and it really means a lot for you
guys to show up to combat talk with the
king yes like really it's just something
that i said you know what i'm watching
the fights and i like to hang out i want
to hang out with you guys
and just you know come drink and we talk
and have uh you know talk about fights
and that's gonna evolve and grow into
its own entity to something else what's
going on
boys i'm in those mediums i can't let
him right now you don't need that
information
you're putting them on the sidewalk
when you get the move and everything
handle man how about you come on the
attic show that we needed to see that we
definitely need to see them
pitching you yo
he moving he's moving out here
mr dead in public with aaron graber and
i can't do it publicly with the facts
facts
was it during your time when you was
talking
okay
so you you're taking more away from your
your outro than i am no i'm just
extending it we're still hungry
no no but listen man um definitely love
each and every last one of you and um
even if you don't super chat understand
it's about you being here spending time
with facts and us you know having a
rapport with you
and and i want to say i i saw something
that was a real heavy subject a real
heavy subject that is dividing our
country all over the place and it was a
company that was taking their stance on
their uh principles and their beliefs
and and and that's that's great but at
the same time i find the comedy in
everything and i just wanted to bring
comedy to such a heavy situation even
though sometimes you you can't laugh at
everything but you can't be all serious
all the time
there's jokes in there
for us to have and we always got to be
level-headed and clear yeah so remember
guys we play video games you know and
we're supposed to be a brotherhood
sisterhood family so let's let's let's
keep it there do that yeah absolutely
the same thing same same with me that's
why like the the series that's time i
see like people were making this a real
beef topic and i'm just like yo this is
funny like
if we know what's going on you got to
have some fun with the topics i love
what you did you know what i'm saying
but yeah she looked everybody in the
chat look we about to do our thing and
get up on out of here anything else
adding anything else we good we paid the
bills everything good uh
make sure that enjoy that okay now we're
good
just to remind the chat we are having
that xbox prediction on the fifth of
next month yes that is still going down
that is still going now all right
everybody enjoy your sunday we out
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
you